bonsoir monsieur jancovici et merci de
nous faire l'honneur de votre présence
ici ce soir pour cette conférence co
organisée par l'association sciences po
environnement et le journal
inter-universitaire la gazelle nous
remercions aussi l'école le nsp est ce
qui a rendu possible cet événement en
nous y accueillons aujourd'hui votre
présence dans un lieu enseignants
majoritairement l'économie les sciences
sociales et la géographie est tout à
fait naturel est justifiée mais cela
n'aurait peut-être pas été le cas il ya
quelques années en 1984 lorsque vous
sortiez brillamment avec un diplôme
d'ingénieur des bancs de l'école
polytechnique
ces années continue à faire partie
intégrante de votre vie puisque vous
êtes encore largement impliqué
aujourd'hui dans beaucoup d'activités de
cet établissement rédacteur dans un
journal mensuel des anciens élèves
la jaune et le rouge implication dans
l'amicale des anciens élèves et enfin
président de l'association x
environnement c'est fini j'ai rendu mon
tablier il ya deux mois
merci de cette précision mais après
après un mandat digne d'un dictateur
africain puisque cela faisait 17 ans
mais depuis la fin des années 90 vous
n'avez cessé de vous intéresser de très
près aux questions d'énergie et de
climat ainsi qu'à leurs répercussions
macroéconomiques
depuis le début des années 2000 vous
êtes entré au comité scientifique puis
stratégique de la fondation nicolas
hulot consultant à l'ademe
vous avez contribué à créer un outil
aujourd'hui incontournable pour qu'elles
quantifier l'impact environnemental le
bilan carbone
ce métier de consultant vous l'avez
prolongé en fondant en 2007 avec un
engrangeant un autre x le cabinet
carbone 4 qui fait office de référence
dans le domaine d'étude de l'impact
carbone
pour exemple carbone 4 a été amené à
participer à l'épineux rapport
interministériel sur le dossier de notre
dame des landes
mais vous avez également de très
nombreuses autres casquettes
conférencier régulier comme nous pouvons
le voir ce soir mais aussi à la
télévision ou radio
enseignant à l'école des mines paristech
les vidéos des cours sont d'ailleurs
consultable par tous auteur de plusieurs
livres de référence sur l'énergie et le
climat comme dormez tranquilles jusqu'en
2100 chroniqueur de presse dans les
échos membre de nombreuses commissions à
la fois publique ou privée président et
fondateur d'un think tank de shift
project vous toucher ainsi directement à
toute une variété d'acteurs dans votre
domaine d'expertisé entreprises du cac40
politiques ong chercheurs journalistes
étudiants mais vous avez également la
volonté de toucher un public varié de
vous affranchir de toute étiquette
politique
informez conseillez interpeller les
décideurs d'aujourd'hui et de demain sur
les impératifs climatiques
tel est peut-être finalement votre
devise on aurait pu vous apercevoir à
des auditions à l'assemblée nationale il
ya deux ans en décembre dernier sur une
chaîne youtube de hackers libertaire
partisans d'edouard snowden ou bien
encore à une réunion organisée par en
marche à genève le 22 mai prochain sur
votre page wikipédia il est mentionné
explicitement que vous voyagez sobrement
il est indiqué que vous ne prenez jamais
l'avion pour des déplacements en france
très peu la voiture et que vous
privilégiez train métro et vélo ma
première réaction a été de me demander
si vous n'aviez pas passer une consigne
à votre community manager après le
scandale des mois dernier sur les
multiples véhicules motorisés de nicolas
hulot mais non une vérification de
l'historique de la page montre que cette
ligne apparaît depuis bien avant et
qu'elle est même source et vers un des
nombreux articles de votre site internet
se passer de voiture au quotidien est ce
possible
paradoxalement au quotidien c'est
peut-être vos plus grands détracteurs
qui font parler d'eux vous vous êtes en
faveur du nucléaire civil vous êtes
régulièrement critiqué par des militants
écologistes de greenpeace ou autre
mais rassurez vous monsieur en cause ici
nous n'avons pas prévu de focaliser la
conférence là dessus à défaut du
polémique aujourd'hui nous avons envie
de parler écologie mais aussi économie
et politique
il est maintenant temps de commencer
cette conférence et je vous demande de
bien vouloir applaudir chaudement
monsieur jean marc jancovici
vous avez raison c'est mieux avant donc
juste pour information la conférence va
être divisé en deux parties
tout d'abord on va échanger sur trois
thèmes donc une première partie sur
l'état de l'énergie en général une
deuxième partie sur les impacts
économiques et enfin une partie sur les
adaptations politiques envisagées et
enfin il restera une demi-heure à la fin
pour que vous puissiez poser vos
questions on va donc commencer sans
images donc la première partie concerne
l'état de l'énergie en général
la première question que j'ai envie de
vous poser
monsieur c'est par rapport en fait au
titre de la conférence qui est
raréfaction de l'énergie
est ce que pour vous l'énergie se
raréfient et est ce que c'est le cas
pour les énergies fossiles et est ce que
c'est le cas aussi pour les énergies
dites vertes
la réponse est oui et non j'ai une
question préalable 1 avant de me lancer
c'est de savoir qui dans la salle n'a
jamais eu droit à la messe north gala il
y en a qui il y en a plus on s'en fout
c'est je raconte la même chose la
conserve et les produits frais ont à peu
près la même tête donc ok
or c'est juste pour éviter d'avoir à
fait désolé pour ceux qui ont déjà
entendu ils font 3 3 avait de pater je
vais commencer à me répondre à la
question en rappelant ce que c'est que
l'énergie
en fait on a
coutume quand on emploie ce mot de
penser qu'on connaît très bien ce dont
il s'agit tout simplement parce qu'une
bonne partie d'entre vous paye des
factures sur lesquels il a marqué
électricité ou gaz ou bien c'est un
terme que vous voyez assez souvent dans
le journal en fait on a tendance à ne
pas comprendre que quand on parle
d'énergie on part tout bêtement de flux
physiques
alors si je développe un tout petit peu
l'énergie c'est avant d'être un sujet de
débat chaud sans mauvais jeu de mots
dans notre pays c'est quelque chose qui
en physique qui permet de quantifier le
changement ceux d'entre vous qui ont
subi des études d'ingénieur dans leur
jeune temps se rappelle peut-être que la
lainière fois ya plusieurs manières de
définir la l'énergie mais enfin moyen
des mines que j'aime bien qui est de
dire que l'énergie c'est ce qui
caractérise le changement d'état d'un
système donc vous avez n'importe quoi
qui change dans le monde qui vous
entoure et l'énergie et ceux qui
quantifie le changement si vous changez
une température une forme une vitesse
n'importe quoi une couleur vous avez de
l'énergie qui entrent en jeu dans cette
affaire
l'énergie peut être entre guillemets
consommer ou entre guillemets produite
c'est à dire elle peut rentrer ou sortir
du système mais il ya de l'énergie qui
entrent en jeu dans cette affaire le
l'énergie est un temps une grandeur
physique elle a la caractéristique
d'être gouvernés par des lois qui nous
échappe c'est à dire qu'on peut les
connaître on peut pas les changer les
lois humaines on les a faites par et
pour les hommes donc si elle nous
plaisent pas on peut les changer les
lois physiques
on peut les comprendre on ne peut pas
les changer donc une fois que la
physique a décidé que ça marchait comme
s'y est pas comme ça ou alors vous
enquiquiner pas je veux faire un cap et
sert aussi bien on peut pas les on peut
pas les changer
donc le l'énergie comme je disais donc
c'est ce qui caractérise un changement
et donc mettre en jeu de l'énergie en
fait c'est changer quelque chose dans le
monde qui nous entoure et ça on n'y
arrive jamais juste avec de l'énergie
sûre si vous avez juste du pétrole ou
juste du gaz ou juste du bois entre les
mains vous en faites rien pour en faire
quelque chose il faut faire passer ça
dans ce rappel un convertisseur c'est
quelque chose qui va être capable
d'exploiter l'énergie et d'en faire
autre chose que l'énergie que vous allez
rentrer dedans par exemple le moteur est
un convertisseur vous rentrez du pétrole
dedans et vous en sortent du mouvement
votre corps est un convertisseur vous
rentrez dedans des hamburgers pas trop
ces gras et vous en sortez du mouvement
un peu de réflexion pour ceux qui sont
bien réveillés
et la chaleur beaucoup de chaleur vous
prenez un ascenseur vous rentrez de
l'électricité vous en sortez du
mouvement c'est c'est en fait tout ce
qu'on appelle utiliser de l'énergie
en fait c'est utiliser un convertisseur
pour créer des flux physiques dans le
monde qui nous entoure
c'est ça utiliser le d'énergie donc en
fait consommer de l'énergie c'est une
expression qui a pas de sens ce que vous
buvez pas du pétrole enfin je vous les
conseille
vous mettez encore moins aux doigts dans
la prise donc consommer de l'énergie en
fait c'est utiliser un convertisseur qui
va vous rendre service
historiquement le seul convertisseur
qu'on utilise est et nous mêmes notre
corps donc on rentre dedans de la grèce
de mammouth et derrière en cours très
vite on tape sur les voisins etc
et puis avec le temps on a réussi à
utiliser d'autres convertisseur machine
à vapeur des bateaux à voile etc
tout ça c'est des engins qui
convertissent de l'énergie en autre
chose donc la marine à voile convertit
l'énergie du vent en transport de
marchandises
alors est-ce que l'énergie sera réussi
la réponse globalement ils n'ont depuis
qu'on a commencé à utiliser de l'énergie
alors ça fait des milliers d'années
qu'on est en transition énergétique dans
l'humanité on n'a jamais arrêté d'être
en transition énergétique
la transition énergétique jusqu'à
maintenant a consisté à empilées les
unes sur les autres toutes les énergies
qu'on a réussi à mobiliser à notre
profit donc historiquement on était 100%
aux nerfs donc pour ceux d'entre vous
qui rêvent de 100% au prg bonnes
nouvelles s'arrêtent déjà existé il ya
deux siècles on était 100% aux nerfs
petit souci on était cinq cents millions
d'agriculteurs à 25 ans d'espérance de
vie à la naissance
donc on peut y retourner il ya aucun
problème être 100% weiner avec 7 ou 8
milliards d'individus vivant comme on
vit aujourd'hui c'est un débat un peu
plus compliqué mais ici tout ce qui
compte
indépendamment de la taille de la
population et de son espérance de vie
c'est de redevenir ce en pensant aux
nerfs on peut y arriver physiquement et
strictement aucun problème
donc si je reviens à la question dsk
elle se raréfie aujourd'hui la réponse
est non ce faire que si on regarde la
consommation d'énergie c'est-à-dire la
quantité de machines qu'on utilise en
fait c'est ça que l'humanité mobilise à
son profit depuis un siècle et demi
c'est l'explosion a été multiplié par
plus de 100 et du coup la production
industrielle avec maintenant si on
regarde l'énergie par personne ou si on
regarde l'énergie dans certaines zones
alors je vais prendre les deux exemples
qui sont l'europe d'abord et l' ocde
ensuite en le cd e pour ceux d'entre
vous qui sont pas familiers
l'organisation de coopération et
développement économiques
c'est l'ensemble de ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler les pays développés toute
l'europe de l'ouest les états unis la
corée du sud le canada l'australie le
japon et dans cet ensemble la
l'utilisation de l'énergie pas dire
consommation est passée par un maximum
en 2006 donc deux ans avant lehman
brothers trois ans avant la grande crise
financière de 2009
vous avez un maximum à la quantité
d'énergie disponible dans cette zone
alors c'est quoi l'énergie disponible
dans cette zone c du charbon du pétrole
du gaz un peu de bois un peu de
nucléaire peu d'hydroélectricité et 3
poudre de perlimpinpin pas par-dessus
l'éolien et le solaire le maximum en
2006 dans cette zone est liée au fait
que la production de pétrole
conventionnel sert tout ce qui n'est pas
les sables bitumineux et le pétrole de
schiste passe par un maximum dans le
monde en 2006 aussi et depuis ça décline
cette production laruns donc encore une
fois je parle pas des shale oil et je
parle pas du des sables bitumineux par
habitant non
globalement alors dans les pays dits
avancés qui sont très dépendants du
pétrole c'est le pétrole qui est la
première énergie consommée dans ces pays
eh bien depuis 2006 la quantité globale
d'énergie disponibles dans ces pays est
en contraction et à la suite comme la
quantité de machines qui peut
fonctionner est elle aussi en
contraction puisque s'il ya moins
d'énergie en haut il ya moins de
nourriture pour machines vous avez
également une production industrielle
qui est en contraction dans ces pays là
globalement quatre la production
industrielle dans la zone ocde
aujourd'hui il soit son niveau soit
légèrement en dessous de ce qu'elle
était en 2007 en europe elle est en
dessous globalement dans le monde donc
l'énergie sera réussie pas globalement
dans le monde par personne l'énergie a
fortement crû jusqu'à la fin des trente
glorieuses c'est à dire au moment des
chocs pétroliers 74 79
depuis sa croix beaucoup moins vite
depuis 2004 2005 s'accroît quasiment
plus et si je regarde les pays de l'
ocde l'énergie par personne a fortement
crû jusqu'à la fin des chopes la faim
jusqu'à la fin des trente glorieuses
elle est restée stable entre les trente
glorieuses et 2006 l'énergie par
personne dans la zone ocde et elle
décroît y compris aux états unis depuis
2006 mais est-ce qu avec les impératifs
climatiques
elle va avoir tendance à se raréfier
justement alors ça ça serait la belle
version de l'histoire
la version réelle c'est que l'énergie se
raréfient dans une zone quand il y en a
plus assez physiquement point barre
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de lien entre les grandes déclarations
le coeur sur la main ou la main sur le
coeur j'ai jamais
sur le climat et ce qui se passe pour de
vrai deux exemples en ce qui concerne
l'europe là l'efficacité carbone du pib
c'est à dire la quantité de co2 qu'il
faut émettre pour faire un dollar de pip
a été divisé par trois sur les 50
dernières années aux etats-unis c'est
exactement pareil donc il n'ya pas de
tellement on avait oublié d'allumer le
machin comme quoi un temps en temps la
vie tient à peu de choses et donc pas
écouter s'il ya l'image un jour on
servirait sinon mais fera quand on fera
sans donc le donc le donc les
déclarations aujourd'hui en faveur du
climat
on va continuer comme ça les
déclarations en faveur du climat
aujourd'hui n'ont pas d'effets non on va
dès qu'on va continuer comme ça cherchez
pas changé l'improvisation eux n'ont pas
de nom pas d'effet sur ce qui se passe
réellement quand on regarde les séries
longues alors là une petite une petite
recommandation à l'attention de tous les
gens qui sont dans la salle et qui
doivent un jour prendre des décisions ou
qui en prendront un jour quand vous
regardez quand vous essayez de
comprendre comment le passé se décrit
regarder toujours les séries les plus
longue possible
envoyez un article de journal qui vous
explique qu'il ya telle évolution qui
est en route parce que d'une année sur
l'autre ça augmenter ou baisser de 2% en
mai tel truc à la corbeille et vaut
l'oublier
il faut regarder des séries sur quelques
décennies voire plus pour comprendre ce
qui est en train de se passer
éventuellement les séries courtes ne
vous apprennent rien strictement rien
donc si si les décisions politiques
n'influe pas par rapport aux intérêts
stif climatique
est ce que dans ce cas là c'est pas
intéressant de se pencher sur des
notions d'efficacité énergétique
d'amélioration de fond pourrait en
théorie je vais vous livrer ma
nomenclature delà de ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler d'efficacité énergétique en
fait les économies d'énergie j'ai fini
par me dire que c'était bien de les
ranger dans trois tiroirs distincts il
ya un premier tiroir qui s'appelle
l'efficacité et l'efficacité c'est
disposer du même service qu'avant en
utilisant moins d'énergie pour le
service en question
donc si par exemple vous continuer à
rouler dans une voiture qui fait le même
poids qui va à la même vitesse et qui
vous emmène
même manière la grand-mère le canari et
le chien mais qu'elle consomme moins ça
s'appelle de l'efficacité c'est ce qui
va beaucoup aujourd'hui si vous allez
voir si vous continuer à habiter dans la
même surface habitable qui soit dit en
passant a quasiment doublé entre 74 et
2000 sa surface habitable par personne
en france
si vous habitez dans la même surface
habitable qui consomme moins d'énergie
pour vous procurer le même confort
thermique
ça s'appelle de l'efficacité si vous
achetez une paire de chaussures qui a
demandé moins d'énergie pour être
fabriqué
ça s'appelle de l'efficacité cette
première catégorie d'économies d'énergie
est quelque chose que tout le monde
adore pour deux raisons la première
c'est qu'elle reporte la charge de
l'effort sur les industriels et les
ingénieurs
donc c'est vachement sympa vous dites
moi je suis assis dans mon fauteuil
j'achèterais une voiture qui consomme
moins le jour où ces branleurs de chez
peugeot voudront bien me donner une
et tant qu'on n'en est pas là je vois
pas pourquoi je ferais un effort
quelconque
pareil pour les chaussures le jour où on
voudra bien me donner des chaussures qui
ont été fabriqués avec moins d'énergie
aussi possible pas par des pakistanais
est compensée en co2 je les achèterai
tant que j'en suis prête et pas plus
cher
il entre les deux chevaux et délaisse un
temps et aujourd'hui a pas eu beaucoup
d'efficacité si un peu voilà donc elle a
une première vertu cette efficacité
c'est qu'elle reporte la charge encore
une fois sur les ingénieurs la deuxième
vertu de cette efficacité
c'est qu'elle se suffit à elle-même et
elle n'est pas récessive dit autrement
vous pouvez augmenter l'efficacité en
même temps que vous augmentez la
consommation d'énergie globale et donc
le pib global est en fait depuis que on
s'excite sur les questions d'efficacité
historiquement c'est ce qui s'est passé
tout a augmenté en même temps la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise le pib
et l'efficacité
la deuxième catégorie d'économie
d'énergie je l'appelle la sobriété la
sobriété c'est un abandon délibéré
consenti de service qui permet du coup
de ne pas consommer l'énergie associée
au service je vous donnais deux ou trois
exemples la colocation souhaité et de la
sobriété vous diminuer la quantité de
mètres carrés par personne parce que
vous mutualiser la cuisine la salle de
bain le salon etc
les couloirs
le covoiturage une forme de sobriété
n'achetez pas de voiture vous squattez
celle des autres donc il y en a chez les
autres c'est une forme de sobriété la
sobriété permet donc d'économiser de
l'énergie puisque vous abandonnez
délibérément des services qui ne
nécessite pas vous achetez moi un truc
des fringues problème si vous ne
consommez pas on ne produit pas donc
c'est récessif donc la sobriété elle est
récessif et vous avez une version subi
de la sobriété que j'appelle la pauvreté
la pauvreté c'est de la sobriété suivi
c'est à dire que vous n'avez pas accès
aux services mais au lieu que vous
l'ayez choisir via pas demander votre
avis vous pouvez plus la grosse
différence entre les deux évidemment
c'est la contrepartie sociale la
sobriété on peut à la rigueur s'imaginer
qu'elle est heureuse
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui sont
heureux dans la sobriété tous les gens
qui partent camper l'été ils abandonnent
plein de service et ils peuvent être
très heureux voilà la pauvreté n'est pas
heureuse puisqu'elle est suivie voilà
donc c'est ça les trois catégories
d'économie d'énergie alors l'efficacité
malheureusement elle n'est pas
suffisante en tant que tels si on ne
limite pas les services dans le même
temps c'est à dire si vous dites
aujourd'hui j'ai jeu pourquoi 1
milliards de machines à laver dans le
monde
je vais les rendre vachement plus
efficace et je maintiens 1 milliards de
machines à laver vous pouvez imaginer
que la consommation d'énergie des
machines à laver baisse il a en même
temps il faut pas se rajouter autre
chose qui va vous consommez l'énergie
libérée par les machines mais
historiquement sait jamais ce qui s'est
passé il ya eu ce qu'on a rappelé les
faits rebond c'est à dire si la machine
à laver consomme moins elle devient plus
accessible et du coup il ya plus de gens
qu'on achète
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé pour
les voitures on parlait tout à l'heure
de la deux chevaux la deux chevaux dans
laquelle j'ai appris à conduire
consommer 5 litres aux cent la twingo
d'aujourd'hui consomme 5 litres aux cent
sauf que la deux chevaux à l'époque
peser 500 kg elle faisait 90 km/heure de
vitesse de pointe et 6 ans antibes étude
de cylindrée pour la twingo vous avez un
litre et demi de cylindrée ça fait cent
soixante s'apaisent plus d'une tonne et
c'est donc il ya eu énormément
d'efficacité unitaire si vous ramenez ou
km/heure de vitesse de pointe s'est par
contre si vous regardez la consommation
de l'objet de 3 5 litres au cent fera
pas bouger et à l'époque où j'ai appris
à conduire il y avait quelques centaines
de millions de voitures dans le monde
de mémoire j'ai envie de dire deux ou
trois cents millions aujourd'hui en à 1
milliard donc le l'efficacité en tant
que telle elle n'est pas suffisante
ce qu'il faut pour que vous ayez des
économies d'énergie en valeur absolue
vers la quantité totale de pétrole ou de
gaz ou de charbon en consomment il faut
que vous rajoutiez des contraintes par
dessus qui sont soit des contraintes
économiques soient des normes sociales
c'est parfait c'est nos deux parties
suivantes par rapport aux notions de
d'efficacité énergétique
il ya des notions que dont vous parlez
assez souvent par rapport à alain elle
investit aux investissements
énergétiques nécessaires pour récolter
les ressources
je pense par exemple à des indicateurs
comme l'héroïne dont vous parlez
justement par rapport à la réfection de
l'énergie pour pour dire que c'est de
plus en plus dur d'avoir accès l'énergie
l'héroïque pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
sont pas au courant c'est pas une
version dégradée de l'héroïsme c'est un
acronyme qui veut dire energy return en
énergie investec
alors c'est quoi ce de cette notion sais
combien vous devez mettre d'énergie dans
le système énergétique pour extraire de
l'énergie de l'environnement
alors pour expliquer pourquoi c'est
important je vais revenir à une notion
barbare de physique en physique
il ya une loi cardinal quand on parle
d'énergie qui s'appelle la loi de
conservation de l'énergie
donc la loi de conservation elle est
bien faite elle dit un truc tout bête
elle dit que dans un système qui ne
communiquent pas avec l'extérieur
l'énergie conserve si vous prenez un
système isolé du monde qui l'entourent
à l'intérieur de ce système la quantité
totale d'énergie reste rigoureusement
stable l'augmentent parole baisse pas
rigoureusement une fois que on a compris
cette loi qui s'appelle aussi le premier
principe de la thermodynamique
on comprend une chose c'est que les
hommes ne peuvent rien faire d'autre que
d'extraire de l'environnement une
énergie qui existe déjà
si on était capable de créer comme ça là
sur ma main de l'énergie ça voudrait
dire qu'on serait capable de violer le
premier principe de la thermodynamique
et comme je le disais tout à l'heure les
lois physiques ne viole pas vrai
doit lui mais non peu les doigts
physique on ne peut pas enfin dans leur
domaine de validité on peut pas donc
tout ce qu'on peut faire en ce qui
concerne l'énergie c'est aller chercher
dans l'environnement une énergie qui
existe déjà
sauf que pour aller chercher dans
l'environnement une énergie qui existe
déjà il faut dépenser de l'énergie par
exemple pour aller chercher du pétrole
il faut fabriquer des tubes en acier
sans sa demande de l'énergie du charbon
l'occurrence il faut déplacer les
ingédients surpayés de total et
schlumberger et technip sur site
rigolez pas y en a peut-être un an la
salle si on regarde bien des fois y'a
souvent il faut une fois que le pétrole
a été extrait l'acheminer jusqu'à son
lieu de consommation
ça va vous demander un peu d'énergie et
puis soit dit en passant vous ne
consommez pas du pétrole brut et vos
voitures ne consomme pas du pétrole brut
vous consommez des produits raffinés
donc il faut raffiner le pétrole raffiné
de pétrole c'est le show fait très fort
pour le distiller et ça ça consomme de
l'énergie en fait c'est la première
dépense énergétique de la chaîne
pétrolière tout ça va vous bouffer entre
15 et 20% de l'énergie contenue dans le
pétrole extrait ce qui veut dire que
quand vous allez chercher sans sous
terre vous pouvez mettre 80 à la
disposition de la société pour faire
autre chose que d'aller chercher du
pétrole
si vous aviez besoin de sens pour aller
chercher 100 c'est game over
vous ne pouvez mettre aucun
kilowattheure à disposition de la
société
toute l'énergie est consommée par le
système énergétique pour aller chercher
de l'énergie dans l'environnement
donc il en sort rien pour alimenter vos
voitures les établissements
d'enseignement et le restaurant d'à côté
ou fabriquer des vêtements
rien donc historiquement ce que les
hommes ont toujours cherché à faire
c'est d'aller d'énergie à faible 0 hiver
d énergie à plus fort héroïque et
l'énergie qui a le meilleur
le héros y de tout c'est le pétrole à
ses origines
donc quand le colonel drac qui était pas
un colonel soit dit en passant allez
donné trois coups de pioche en
pennsylvanie et qu'il se retrouvait
assis sur le geyser de pétrole là comme
dans les bons du qui lui qu à cette
époque là le héros y du pétrole étaient
de 1 % c'est-à-dire que vous aviez
besoin de 1 kilowatt heure mis dans le
système énergétique pour faire sens pour
faire sortir 100 kilowatts heure de
terre aujourd'hui avec les sables
bitumineux ou avec le shale oil on est
plutôt un pour trois ans chez lloyd
c'est un peu monté aujourd'hui ça doit
être un pour quatre points pour 5 mai
par contre
les sables bitumineux c'est un pur 3
c'est comme les s'habitue bidos et du
bitume comme son nom l'indiqué c'est du
sable imprégné de bitume
il faut chauffer extrêmement fort pour
rentrer et distillé très fort pour
rendre ce truc là un peu fluide
l'hydrogène et et lui donner une vague
tête des sens donc ça veut dire que pour
trois barils extraits vous en avez
consommé 1 évidemment c'est beaucoup
moins intéressant c'est pour ça que
c'est beaucoup plus cher c'est beaucoup
plus capitalistiques et surtout vous
pouvez avec la même quantité d'énergie
investi dans le système vous en faites
sortir beaucoup moins le héros y de là
qu'est ce que je vais dire du vent ou du
solaire est moins bon que le héros y du
pétrole alors ce qui a permis la
civilisation industrielle s'est
notamment d'aller d'énergie à faible
héros y verrez des énergies à fort
héroïque terre jusqu'aux pétrole on a
empilé les énergies les unes sur les
autres mais en allant d'énergie pas
commode à utiliser vers des énergies de
plus en plus commode à utiliser de plus
en plus dense par unité de volume de
plus en plus dense par unité de masse
etc
depuis le pétrole on perd sert le gaz
c'est un peu moins efficace que le
pétrole le nucléaire c'est un peu moins
efficace que le gaz et le pétrole le
vent c'est un peu moins c'est encore
moins efficace c'est bien pour le lieu
le nucléaire les avis se quelques
dizaines on va dire
les analyses divergent selon que vous
êtes a priori pourront a priori contre
le vent on est aujourd'hui aux alentours
de 1 pour 10 mais il faut bien voir que
l'éolien et le solaire ça reste quand
même des produits de la mondialisation
aujourd'hui les panneaux solaires sont
fabriqués dans trois pays dans le monde
et distribué installés partout ailleurs
grâce au pétrole
le vent est fabriquée enfin les
éoliennes sont fabriqués dans trois ou
quatre pays dans le monde et distribué
partout ailleurs érigé sur des socles en
béton qui sont faits grâce au charbon et
c'est donc pour le moment le système est
couplé est en fait la bonne question
c'est que devient l'héroïne le jour où
vous n'avez plus que des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes pour fabriquer
d'autres panneaux solaires et autres
éoliennes est à mon avis la casse la
gueule parce que sur le papier ils ont
un meilleur héroïque sur wii dès son
décollage mais mais mais c'est un
système couplé encore une fois si vous
devez demain matin avoir que des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes pour
faire même le mining enfin je veux dire
aller chercher les métaux dans les mid
faire l'habitat lurgi ah bon la chimie
amont toute la transformation
manufacturière derrière et le transport
à travers le monde
vous allez voir le prix de l'éolien et
du solaire et vous allez voir le héros y
du bastringue
c'est évident que tout ça va se dégrader
par rapport aux énergies vertes
enfin dites vertes est-ce que les
recyclages et et au niveau de deux des
enjeux actuels et est ce que quand on
regarde le cycle de vie totale de ces
énergies et est ce que il est capable de
permettre cette vraie de transition dont
en train de parler énergies vertes je
sais pas qui a inventé énergie verte
j'ai pas pu mettre des guillemets
j'aimerais bien je serais curieux de
savoir qui a pour la première fois
inventé ce terme
moi j'en aurais pu inventer énergie
pleut ou nrj rose ou nrj je roule je
n'ai pas fait un bon bref énergies
vertes
en fait il faut il faut distinguer deux
choses quand on parle des énergies
vertes des énergies renouvelables il ya
l'énergie elle même qui peut être
renouvelable et son dispositif de
collecte qui peut ne pas l'être du tout
or aujourd'hui quand on parle de
l'éolien ou du solaire on parle à la
fois d'une énergie qui est renouvelable
et d'un dispositif de collecte qui
aujourd'hui est le fruit de notre
civilisation fossiles photovoltaïque
c'est le fruit notre civilisation
fossiles l'éolien c'est enfin les
éoliennes moderne
c'est le fruit de notre civilisation
fossiles dans une éolienne moderne vous
avez quelques dizaines de métaux divers
vraiment le fruit de notre civilisation
fossile donc est ce que les énergies
vertes sont verte les énergies oui leur
dispositif de collecte non il est
tributaire de la civilisation
industrielle pour lancer ça renvoie à la
remarque précédente
est-ce qu'on continuera à voir des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires pour
pas cher le jour où on aura plus que des
les fabriquer là la réponse est c'est
pas sûr
et du reste le héraut id d'un système
dans lequel vous n'auriez que du solaire
et de l'éolien pour fabriquer du solaire
et de l'éolien j'ai pas fait le calcul
mais à mon avis il dépasse pas quelques
unités orient un homme s'appelle
masselot qui a expliqué que pour avoir
une civilisation telle que vous la
connaissez aujourd'hui avec du temps
libre pour venir écouter ce genre de
conférences inutile plus une
productivité fabuleuse du travail qui
permet d'avoir le cinéma la santé les
transports pour tous etc
il faut un peu héroïque globale du
système qui soit au dessus de 10 j'ai
pas fait les calculs mais ça me paraît
intuitivement pertinents ce qui est une
autre manière de dire que par exemple
les énergies vertes qui
s'autoalimenterait permettrait pas
d'avoir comme on a aujourd'hui système
de santé le système éducatif etc et ça à
mon avis c'est le problème ça renvoie ce
que c'est tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
civilisation 100% weider encore une fois
historiquement s'arrêter pour la techno
est passée par là avait historiquement
ça a été 500 millions d'agriculteurs 25
ans d'espérance de vie à la naissance
c'était ça la civilisation surpassant le
lr est ce qu'avec la technologie moderne
on ferait beaucoup mieux j'en sais rien
c'est un ses intérêts ça serait
intéressant de regarder la seule chose
avec laquelle je pourrais compléter ce
propos c'est pour le moment je n'ai pas
croisé un scénario crédible 100%
urinaire émanant d'un organisme de place
quand on commence à regarder un peu les
potentiomètres derrière il ya des trucs
délirants dans tous les sens et en
particulier
ça ne tient pas compte des effets
système que je viens d'évoquer du
couplage avec les énergies fossiles
tous les gens qui pensent que les ailes
ces eaux-là fallait les coûts globaux
vont continuer à baisser
en fait il postule que la civilisation
va devenir de plus en plus dopé aux
combustibles fossiles c'est ça qui
postulent quelque part c'est un peu
curieux quand on va vers un système 100%
weider bon on va peut-être passer
maintenant à la partie plus liés à
l'économie
quels sont les liens qu'entretiennent de
manière générale les systèmes
économiques avec l'énergie alors ils
entretiennent pas lien c'est justement
ça le problème
et commencer par une petite blague si la
terre avait un comptable terre pour
l'avoir comptable le comptable pourrais
vous dire mais sur les hommes les femmes
les femmes à chaque fois que vous
retirez un peu de pétrole dans un puits
de pétrole ce pétrole ne se reformera
parce qu'il faut 50 à 300 millions
d'années pour faire du pétrole donc vous
allez me passer une dotation aux
amortissements pour avoir supprimé un
peu des stocks de pétrole
il ya chaque fois que vous retirez du
minerai de cuivre d'une mine vous allez
me passer une dotation aux
amortissements pour tout le monde sait
ce que c'est qu'une dotation aux
amortissements ou pas non alors j'ai
commencé par ça quand vous faites de la
comptabilité d'entreprise vous avez deux
manière de comptabiliser ce que vous
payez les charges
vous avez les charges courantes pour
lesquelles vous comptabilisez la
totalité de la dépense au moment où vous
sortez l'argent vous achetez une ramette
de papier c'est les charges courantes
donc c'est à vous de comptabiliser la
totalité de la dépense au moment où vous
achetez votre à m et puis vous pouvez
acheter des choses qui sont des stocks
ou des actifs donc par exemple vous
achetez un stock de vie ce parce que
vous êtes un fabricant de plaques avec
des vis dedans et votre stock de vie
s'il va vous duré cinq ans vous achetez
le stock est à ce moment en comptabilité
vous passez pas en charge la totalité
des achats du stock au moment où vous
l'achetez ce que vous allez passer en
charge c'est la fraction du stock que
vous consommez dans l'année si vous
achetez une machine qui dure plusieurs
années
vous allez par vous acheter des
fauteuils là par exemple auditives ont
duré dix ans et bien vous allez
comptabilisés dans vos charges un
dixième du prix d'achat du fauteuil
chaque année encore bon qu'en fait vous
avez une opération qui s'appelle une
dotation aux amortissements jab orties
je diminue
1 la valeur de ce que j'ai dans mon
actif d'une petite fraction tous les ans
alors ce principe de dotations aux
amortissements évidemment en
macroéconomie on n'applique pas c'est
quand je fabrique un fauteuil j'ai prix
du minerai de fer dans la croûte
terrestre
à aucun moment j'ai diminué la valeur
résiduelle des stocks de minerai de fer
je pourrais le faire je le fais pas
j'ai utilisé du charbon métallurgique
pour faire vaciller
j'ai diminué les stocks de charbon il a
fallu 300 millions d'années pour faire
du charbon c
l'histoire d'une fois on recommencera
pas donc je pourrais et puis il ya un
deuxième truc que j'ai pas fait dans
cette histoire c'est passé une provision
pour risques alors c'est pareil dans la
comptabilité des entreprises quand vous
faites quelque chose qui vous met en
danger pour l'avenir par exemple vous
viré avec pertes et fracas salariés qui
va aller porter plainte aux prud'hommes
et bien vous passez dans vos comptes une
provision pour risque zéro dit ouh là il
ya un risque que je paye quelque chose
plus tard on craque
j'ai inscrit tout de suite la charge
correspondante dans mes comptes alors
avec le changement climatique par
exemple à chaque fois que les fabriquer
un fauteuil j'ai mis du co2 dans
l'atmosphère j'ai contribué au
changement climatique ça va occasionner
des dégâts plus tard j'ai pas passer de
charges pour ça alors maintenant je vais
vous parler de la station spatiale
internationale faisait tout ce que c'est
que la station spatiale là le terrain de
jeu de super skis bon ça vaut 100
milliards de dollars si je joue donc
pour mettre une grosse boîte de conserve
dans l'espace sans milliard de dollars
alors cette boîte de conserve qu'est ce
qu'elle vous assure comme si comme
service elle vous assure la possibilité
de pouvoir respirer lorsque sinon dans
le vide intersidéral juste à côté pour
ce qu'ont vu gravity donc j'espère pas
bien elle vous assure la possibilité de
pas mourir congelés jeu toujours pareil
dans le vide intersidéral juste à côté
il fait assez froid quel quelques degrés
kelvin pas beaucoup plus et puis elle
vous assure de pouvoir boire même s'il
faut monter un peu d'eau dans la station
en recyclant vos propre urine mais je ne
vous ai rien dit comment donc trois
services un cycle de l'eau élémentaire
une atmosphère respirable
le fait de pas mourir congelés trois
services 15 milliards de dollars par
personne
la terre nous offre ces trois services
la plus 30 millions d'espèces vivantes
plus des minerais plus un océan plus un
système climatique plus la neige qui
tombe à noël les bonnes années et plus
et enfin bon bref tout un tas de trucs
donc jeudi la terre vaut au moins 15
milliards de dollars par personne
l'ami non d'accord pas valoir moins
notre activité économique
aujourd'hui mange une partie de ce
capital tous les ans nous mangeons
aujourd'hui le stock de combustible
fossile hauteur de l'ordre d'un pour
cent par an nous mangeons le stock de
minerai à hauteur de un pour mille à 1%
par an ça dépend des minerais nous
mangeons le stock de poissons à hauteur
de 1% par an le maximum des captures en
mer c'était 1995 partie 2 les gens dans
la salle étaient peut-être même pas nés
le palois ne fait pas la maille est donc
le capital naturel
on peut considérer aujourd'hui qu'on le
mange à hauteur d'au moins 1% moi je
vais être conservateur je dirais pour
1000 dont 15 milliards de dollars par
personne
le capital naturel j'en mange un pour
mille par an j'ai donc une dotation aux
amortissements a passé de 15 millions de
dollars par an est d'accord et par
personne en face de ça la production
économique ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler
la création de richesses ses 15000
dollars par personne et par an le pib
par personne donc le système terre
aujourd'hui s'il avait un comptable
le comptable nous collerait à la barre
du tribunal de commerce en disant hé les
mecs vous êtes en faillite chaque année
vous dépenser mille fois plus que ce que
vous gagnez à la barre du tribunal de
commerce
donc c'est quoi le rapport qu'entretient
c'était la longue réponse à la courte
question l'économie avec l'environnement
la réponse est zéro y en a pas et y en a
pas parce que quand l'économie classique
celle qu'on enseigne aujourd'hui à
sciences po jeu désolé d'être un peu
désagréable a été théorisé et bien les
économistes classiques ont dit on va
s'occuper de ce qui est rare c'est ça
l'économie à l'époque est ce que les
ressources naturelles sont rares non je
le rappelle on est encore une fois 500
millions d'agriculteurs sur une terre
immense boucle et ressources naturelles
on s'en fout le seul facteur limitant
pour la production d'origine humaine
c'est la paire de bras le nombre de
paires de bras qui peut travailler
donc on va s'occuper du travail et le
capital humain qu'on est capable de
mobiliser
donc on va s'occuper du capital dans
lequel il y avait quelque chose qui
s'apparente et des ressources naturelles
qui avait la terre mais en fait c'était
la terre cultivable c'était la terre
possédés par les hommes
la terre posséder l'antarctique à
l'époque était toujours pas dans les
comptes des conneries
et puis cette approximation au premier
ordre qui a même été explicité de
manière magistrale par jean baptiste say
dans son traité d'économie politique
oui dit il écrit les ressources
naturelles sont gratuites car action
illimitée
je décris eh bien il a dit ça il ya deux
siècles et rigoler sauf qu'aujourd'hui
c'est toujours l'économie qu'on enseigne
c'est toujours l'économie
on enseigne c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la fonction de production est une
fonction du capital et du travail
et quand monsieur solo dit je vais
expliquer la croissance par la
croissance du capital et du travail
il rate les trois quarts de ce qu'ils
observent et donc il fait une équation
qu'on a juste exposé c'est quand même le
truc le plus hallucinant que j'ai jamais
vu on fait une équation fausseront rang
juste en l'ajustant exposé tous les ans
si n'importe qui dans cette salle qui
travaille dans une entreprise fait des
comptes de l'entreprise comme ça
longtemps donc le donc la macroéconomie
aujourd'hui elle est fausse durera
jusqu'à z
parce que elle a oublié que pour faire
des fauteuils il faut certes des
ouvriers pour transformer des ressources
il faut certes des machines mais il faut
des ressources pour alimenter la machine
il faut l'énergie pour alimenter la
machine donc si vous n'avez pas les
ressources qui nous entourent dont
l'énergie la production nuls donc si
vous mettez des banquiers compatissant
et des travailleurs motivés au milieu du
vide intersidéral leur production sera
rigoureusement nul zéro
merci pourtant dans l'impression que
pour créer des richesses on a besoin
d'utiliser de l'énergie on a besoin
d'eux
donc il ya quand même un lien entre la
croissance économique telle qu'on
l'entend et la consommation de
ressources oui mais on a inversé le lien
c'est à dire que là où c'était une
condition nécessaire on en a fait une
commodité appelé hier qu'aujourd'hui
l'énergie s'est vu comme un truc qui
s'achète et comme soit dit en passant ça
vaut quelques pour cents des dépenses
regardez une entreprise comme la sncf
sur le devant de l'actualité mais pour
d'autres raisons
c'est quand même une entreprise qui
exploite d'énormes machines en tgv ça
fait ch pourquoi 10 15 mégawatts
il y en a des centaines enfin je veux
dire c'est une entreprise industrielle
ses premiers consommateurs industriels
d'électricité en france le la sncf donc
c'est quand même une énorme machine
industrielle la sncf est bien dans une
entreprise comme la sncf l'énergie ces
trois pour cent de leurs charges donc si
vous supprimez l'énergie de la sncf ya
plus un train qui avance si vous
supprimez 3% de la masse salariale ça
pose aucun problème
n'en déplaise aux cheminots donc c'est
bien la preuve que la part dans les
charges n'est absolument pas
proportionnelle à l'importance de
l'énergie dans le système économique
on voit ça comme que c'est un peu comme
si je vous disais votre pancréas
c'est je pense combien votre cervelle
ces 2 % votre masse donc on va dire le
pancréas et 0 2%
je vous le dire c'est pas grave j'ai
rien où je vais baisser votre efficacité
de 0 2% un peu plus compliqué que ça
donc le la dépendance de l'économie à
l'énergie n'est absolument pas reflété
par sa part temps les charges de même
que la dépendance de votre foyer à
l'électricité n'est absolument pas
reflétée par la part de l'électricité
dans vos charges si demain matin je vous
coupe la bonne l'alimentation électrique
d'un logement pour six mois
vous assurez que assez rapidement vous
allez avoir un certain nombre de
problèmes à l'intérieur
donc vous avez et si je coupe
l'électricité pour six mois dans une
ville
je pense que la moitié des gens qui
meurent plus de transport plus de chaîne
du froid plus de plus d'alimentation
plus d'enfants plus tôt
commence à poser quelques petits
problèmes quoi donc vous donc la
dépendance systémique à l'énergie n'est
absolument pas représentée par sa
fraction dans les coûts et donc en
économie c'est un truc qu'on ne comprend
pas c'est à dire que comme les gens y
pensent
euroskypark complètement illogique pour
des gens qui s'occupent d'économies il
pense que l'énergie c'est un truc dont
il faut s'occuper parmi d'autres choses
et que c'est quand même plus important
de s'occuper des retraites et moi ce que
je dis c'est 100 d'énergie aura pas de
retraite de toutes façons notamment la
peine de s'en occuper
donc l'énergie coûte assez cher qu'elle
devrait coûter et c'est oui ou plus
exactement si on regarde les services
qu'elle rend ça n'est absolument pas
reflété par sa part dans les structures
de couches de prendre un dernier exemple
imaginons que vous soyez dans une
entreprise industrielle dans une
entreprise industrielle la puissance du
parc de machines c'est des milliers ou
des millions de fois la puissance des
ouvriers qui y travaillent la puissance
musculaire des ouvriers qui travaillent
donc si on devait comptabiliser les
charges dans une entreprise
d'industriels à proportion de la
contribution des machines et des hommes
dans la transformation de la matière la
masse salariale devrait représenter un
pour mille de la facture énergétique
je répète voilà c'est ça la réalité du
service que nous rend l'énergie
donc on peut dire effectivement qu'elle
n'est pas assez cher c'est une façon de
le dire
donc il ya beaucoup de il ya pas mal de
pays qui fondent leur espoir de 2 de
croissance sur cette transition
énergétique
je pense par exemple à l'allemagne qui
qui va croire dans une une
dématérialisation de l'économie et une
croissance verte
encore une fois
le mot est associée croissance qu'est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est possible
cette sacro-sainte verte je vais encore
être un peu taquin c'est la façon dont
les journalistes issus de sciences po
pour certains voient l'allemagne c'est
pas du tout ce que l'allemagne dit
qu'elle fait l'allemagne à une
transition qui est de sortir du
nucléaire points l'allemagne à une
hostilité viscérale au nucléaire rien à
voir avec les trucs qu'on voit en france
80% de la population est farouchement
antinucléaire du reste dans l'accord de
coalition qui vient d'être passé entre
les deux grands partis qui arrivent au
pouvoir
il ya une phrase qui dit on fera tout ce
qu'on peut pour torpiller nucléaire en
europe donc le l'allemagne à une
transition qui est on veut pas de
nucléaire
le reste se négocie pour le moment quand
vous regardez ce que fait l'allemagne
pour tout le reste
en gros le climat ils s'en foutent comme
de l'an 40 ils ont décidé de sortir du
nucléaire et de garder leur charbon ils
viennent de gagner une manche à
bruxelles là pour alléger les
contraintes sur les constructeurs
d'automobiles allemand qui peuvent
vendre comme ça des voitures plus
lourdes et qui consomment plus à chaque
fois qu'il s'agit de durcir le système
de quotas de co2 qui s'applique à
l'industrie lourde les premiers à être
vent debout pardon du mauvais jeu de
mots c'est les allemands donc au motif
qu'ils plantent trois éoliennes et de
panneaux solaires tout le monde les
parts de tous les lauriers écologique
mais n'ont rien à voir
l'allemagne en allemagne les émissions
de co2 ces dix tonnes par personne et
par an en france ces moines 6
donc je sais c'est du ce et du french
bashing vue par la presse française que
de pareilles l'allemagne de tous les
lauriers de la transition énergétique
c'est pas du tout ça qu'ils sont en
train de faire je le dis ils sortent du
nucléaire en n'augmentant gaz soit dit
en passant et en augmentant le les
énergies intermittentes sur la partie
énergie intermittente et gaz
un truc aussi qu'on vous dit pas souvent
dans la presse les allemands avaient 100
gigawatts donc 100 milliards de watts de
puissance électrique pilotable en 2002
alors c'est quoi les puissances
pilotable c'est celle que vous pouvez
ajuster en tournant sur un bouton donc
en gros quand le train de 8 heures par
pour but la sncf soit pas en rêve
la deutsche bahn eh bien vous tourner le
bouton vous alimenter les trains et les
trains partent d'accord quand vous
arrivez en amphi ou au travail pour les
plus vieux réveiller ou pas à 9 heures
du matin ou un peu plus tôt et que les
lumières doivent s'allumer et le
vidéoprojecteur fonctionner eh bien on
tourne le bouton et tout ça fonctionne
et bien la puissance pilotable donc en
allemagne c'était 100 milliards de watts
en liga watts en 2002 c'est 100
gigawatts en 2017 mais de paris corps
ils ont baissé de nucléaire ils ont
monté le gaz exactement pareil ils ont
rajouté par dessus des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires parce que c'est pas
pilotable donc si on veut que les trains
de la deutsche bahn partent même quand
ya pas de vent et pas de soleil ce qui
arrive par exemple une journée
anticyclonique où il fait nuit
déjà l'hiver eh bien il faut garder la
puissance pilotable qu'on avait avant
voilà donc ce que tu en train de faire
l'allemagne
c'est quelque chose qui est très
particulier c'est pas du tout quelque
chose qui est réplicable si on veut
baisser les émissions de co2 ça c'est
enfin supprimé du nucléaire qui fait pas
de co2 pour ajouter des nerfs ce qu'ils
font pas de co2 ça change rien aux
émissions de co2 c'est notre et si vous
voulez regarder un modèle de transition
qui me paraît beaucoup plus intéressant
en dehors de la france pour aller
regarder la suède par exemple vous faut
la regarder la grande bretagne grande
bretagne fait des choses extrêmement
intéressante
ils se sont dotés d'un dispositif
institutionnel sur le carbone qui est
assez complet sur une green bank ils ont
un climate change committee qui est
chargé d'aller demander des comptes aux
députés tous les quelques années en dix
ans messieurs les députés qu'avez vous
fait ils essayent à l'anglais c'est tout
ce qui peut produire de l'électricité
bas carbone donc de l'éolien offshore
onshore du solaire le nucléaire etc
puis après que le meilleur gagne
il enfin voila je trouve qu'ils ont une
démarche extrêmement pragmatique les
anglais et les suédois qui ont des
espèces d'anglais du nord sont aussi des
gens qui sont ici sont assez proches les
deux c'est quand vous allez voir les
pratiques
il ya beaucoup de points communs et en
tout cas beaucoup plus de points communs
entre deux que avec nous sur les
pratiques c'est des gens assez
pragmatique alors que les français
aiment bien le grand soir j'aime bien le
grand le grand magicien d'oz qui va
régler tous les problèmes de tout un
chacun vu de son elysées ils sont pas du
tout comme ça les suédois les anglais
donc le donc la transition qui
aujourd'hui pour moi est intéressante
c'est ce qui se passe en suède c'est ce
qui se passe en grande-bretagne s'est
lentement ce qui se passe en finlande
c'est pas inintéressant non plus ce qui
se passe en allemagne c'est tout sauf un
exemple à suivre
j'ai pris l'exemple de l'allemagne mais
c'est un réseau et dans le dos
mais ma question par exemple paris dos
mais ma question porte sur son vélo ma
question passé plus sur le lien entre
croissance et consommation d'énergie
alors mal pensée dedans mon directives
de croissance
mondialement et les deux tiers de la
salle connaissent la cour puisqu'ils
connaissent la messe mondialement quand
vous regardez comment évolue le pib en
fonction de la quantité totale d'énergie
mobilisés donc la quantité totale de
machines mobilisez vous avez une droite
parfaite entre 1965 et 2017 et la raison
pour laquelle vous avez une droite c'est
que la puissance du parc de machines
dans le monde est à tout instant
quelques centaines de fois la puissance
musculaire des hommes donc ce qui
produit vraiment c'est les machines
c'est pas vous produisez pas vous vous
réfléchissez vous commandez les machines
vous appuyer sur des manettes et des
boutons que vous produisez rien du tout
dans une usine de textile c'est pas vous
qui produisent et ses machines dans un
vapocraqueur c'est pas vous qui faites
les monomères qui vont servir à faire
les fibres plastiques c'est la machine
quand vous êtes dans un champ c'est pas
l'agriculteur qui la bourse et la
charrue tirée par le tracteur donc c'est
une machine etc
c'est que les machines qui produisent et
c'est bien parce que les machines
produisent que nous on a le temps d'être
dans cette salle et disserter donc le à
tout instant les machines ces quelques
centaines de fois les machines qui
fonctionnent ces quelques centaines de
fois la puissance musculaire des hommes
donc c'est assez logique que vous ayez
une droite parfaite entre quantité
d'énergie mise en oeuvre et d'ailleurs
dont quantité de machines au travail
epb mais à partir du moment où on va
pouvoir consommer on va devoir consommer
bon même si vous n'avez pas cette
appellation moins d'énergie oui
qu'est-ce qui va les vendre donc le pib
va descendre baroin donc vous pensez que
la décroissance c'est adorable à terme
c'est inexact
alors non seulement je pense qu'elle est
inexorable à terre mais je pense que la
vraie décroissance a commencé dans la
zone ocde depuis 2006 confère ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
parce que quand vous regardez la
production industrielle a fortiori par
tête
elle a baissé depuis 2006 donc vous
pouvez pas acheter des trucs qui sont
pas produits alors on compense un peu en
importe en tant qu on est capable de
faire un peu de création monétaire est
de dire aux gens qu'on les verra demain
mais c'est quand même un terme
d'ajustement qui est marginal
quand vous regardez la quantité de
mètres carrés construits en europe par
exemple s'est passé par un maximum en
2007 quand vous regardez la quantité de
tonnes kilomètre du fret routier en
europe s'est passé par un maximum en
quand vous regardez la production au
sens large industrielle en europe s'est
passé par un maximum en 2007 donc
aujourd'hui la décroissance
elle est déjà là alors les élites bien
nourri de centre ville qui sont dans
cette salle s'en rendent pas compte mais
je peux vous assurer que les électeurs
lepénistes et mélenchonistes de 45 ans
qui craignent de perdre leur boulot et
qui habite à 40 km du centre il semble
tout à fait content tout à fait content
donc donc donc le mouvement est déjà est
déjà là en tendance il va continuer donc
là il ya eu trois années dans l'autre
sens si on aura peut-être une quatrième
parce qu'il ya eu un surplus grâce au
chellah il est
voilà remontée des prix du pétrole mais
c'est structurel ça va continuer à
baisser en tendance donc je pense que le
pib vrai il a déjà fait la production
industrielle à vous avez que
rooseveltien la production industrielle
pour lui si regarder passer les trains
avec des avec des tables et les chaises
dedans comme ça qui compte et non
maintenant qu'on met la drogue et la
prostitution c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais rigolez pas que si si si si si si
si si aux etats unis je crois que si on
espère donc si on essaye on essaye par
tous les moyens de faire remonter ce
foutu pib qui veut qu'il veut plus voilà
donc le donc c'est donc c'est déjà en
train de baisser
donc la bonne question maintenant c'est
comment on s'organise dans ce contexte
là c'est une super transition pour cette
troisième partie quelle politique sait
pas si c'est pas vrai ce que je dis
n'est pas encore prêt dans toutes les
régions du monde
dans les pays dits émergents vous
continuez à avoir un approvisionnements
énergétiques croissants notamment basée
sur le charbon donc l'électricité parce
qu'il faut savoir pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ne le savent pas encore que les deux
tiers du charbon qu'on extrait d'une
mine dans le monde servent à alimenter
une centrale électrique donc le
formidable essor du charbon qu'on a
connus sur les 15 dernières années c'est
la formidable électrification qu'on a
observée en chine en inde et dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays et ne vous
y trompez pas le journal vous tartine
tous les jours des pages sur les nerfs
ce qui a le plus augmenté en production
électrique sur les dix dernières années
est de très loin c'est le charmant c'est
le charbon
je rappelle qu'un j'ai pas fait la
blague tout à l'heure sur la page
wikipédia je vous rappelle qu'une page
wikipedia de langage que la personne qui
a rédigé la page wikipedia et vous savez
pas qui c'est et ça n'engage surtout pas
la personne citée dans la page wikipédia
vous pouvez vous trouver leur nom sur
l'historique oui il n'ya pas le mien
donc vous verrez en ce qui concerne la
page n'est pas le mien donc en face il
ya peut-être une mien il ya dix ans un
moment que j'ai corrigé une énorme
connerie mais pour le reste faut quand
même savoir que sur ma page wikipédia ce
qui me fait vivre est classé dans les
activités accessoires
donc il ya long comme ça sur ce que je
pense sur ceci cela etc
les voisins machin et puis d'un autre
activité dans un coin ya marqué carbone
donc voila et de même ce que vous avez
dans le journal n'engage que l'auteur de
l'article du journal et personne d'autre
donc le pour en revenir à la question de
la croissance ou pas croissance de
l'énergie dans un certain nombre de pays
l'énergie continuent à croître et le pib
à la suite mais tout aura une fin alors
pourquoi est-ce que tout aura une fin
parce que je le dis tout à l'heure le
pétrole le gaz et le charbon ça mais 50
à 400 millions d'années à se constituer
donc aux échelles de temps qui nous
concerne c'est pas renouvelable vous
partez avec une dotation de départ qui
est fixé une fois pour toutes
les mathématiques vous disque quand vous
piochez dans un stock de départ qui est
donnée une fois pour toutes la
consommation issus de ce stock ne peut
rien faire d'autre qu'un big band de
polytechniciens fusion il faut bien que
la case en fait ce que quand vous pour
ceux d'entre vous à qui ça fait pas peur
vous avez une fonction dont l'intégrale
est borné un l'extraction cumulée et
bornés qui est positive et dont vous
êtes capable de démontrer que sa valeur
moyenne sur n'importe quel intervalle
n'ont nulle part de zéro passe par un
maximum et termine à 0
mais moi je sais encore faire ça voulait
pas de ce soir mais c'est encore face à
donc le donc ça veut dire que dès que
vous tapez dans un stock de départ qui
est non renouvelable qui est donnée une
fois pour toutes
vous allez avoir un maximum puis un
déclin à l'extraction du stock donc vous
aurez il est déjà passé pour le
conventionnel
il va arriver dans pas très longtemps
pour le ligue pour les liquides au sens
large un pic à la production mondiale de
pétrole ce qu'on appelle le pétrole vous
aurez un pic à la production mondiale de
charbon vous aurez un pic à la
production mondiale de gaz
vous aurez alors par exemple pour le
charbon c'est très facile de constater
que en europe le pic est arrivé
tant l'arrivée dans les années 80 quand
bretagne il est arrivé au début du 20e
siècle
c'est pas très compliqué de voir que
pour la mer du nord le pic est passé en
2000 pour le pétrole et en 2005 pour le
gaz et voir les statistiques
oui le pic de production du pétrole en
afrique est vraisemblablement passé en
2009 voilà donc vous avez le pic de
pétrole plutôt dans deux productions
pour le pétrole conventionnel donc
encore celle aux etats unis c'est 70
donc vous avez tout un tas de deux
régions dans lesquelles vous pouvez le
constater est ce que je suis en train de
dire vaut pour toutes les ressources qui
alimentent l'industrie
ça vaut aussi pour pardon le minadt
cuivre le tantale l'or l'argent le
chrome le vanadium le brome molybdène et
c'est enfin just limite tous ceux qui
s'extrait de la croûte terrestre passera
par un pic les bonnes questions ne sont
toujours que les mêmes les trois mêmes
qui sont est ce que nous en sommes loin
ou pas est-ce que en valeur absolue le
niveau du pic est très au dessus de la
consommation actuelle ou pas donc je
peux vous dire par exemple l'humanité
s'éteindra sans que nous ayons passé le
pic d'extraction de silice de la croûte
terrestre pour des raisons géologiques
problème l'aluminium il n'aurait
simplement pas de problème l'argent on
est probablement déjà où on n'en est pas
très loin lors on est probablement déjà
où on n'en est pas très loin
le pétrole on n'y est pas très loin et
c'est donc vous avez ça dépend des
ressources
après il ya une deuxième question qui
est est-ce que c'est facile à substituer
ou pas alors il ya des métaux qui sont
faciles à substituer mendeleïev ou plus
exactement mère nature nous a collé 92
éléments donc de temps en temps on peut
permuter un peu là et s'amuser puis il
ya des iade ya des assemblages qui sont
beaucoup plus compliquées a substitué
par exemple le pétrole est très
compliquée a substitué par avec
n'importe quoi très compliqué si vous
voulez substituer par des biocarburants
vous il faudra convertir la totalité de
la production céréalière en biocarburant
que ça ne vous ferais encore que le
quart du pétrole qu'on consomme
aujourd'hui dans le monde
vous oubliez les biocarburants
vous pouvez convertir le charbon en
carburant liquide c'est ce que vite leur
a fait au début de la dernière guerre
c'est comme ça que militaire qui n'avait
pas de pétrole je vous rappelle a quand
même fait voler ses avions moins bien
que les spitfires qui eux avaient des
carburants issus du pétrole c'est pour
ça que les anglais ont résisté enfin
c'est entre autres pour ça que les
anglais ont résisté mais vous pouvez le
faire sauf que vous perdez la moitié de
l'énergie au passage c'est que ça pollue
bah ouais vous perdez la moitié de
l'énergie au passage donc ça sera moins
efficace que le pétrole vous pouvez
synthétiser des carburants liquides avec
du gaz mais c'est moins efficace que le
pétrole etc
donc il ya des trucs qui sont pas
substituables 1 pour 1 on va dire on
peut pas tous remplacés et au moment où
vous passez donc le pic des ressources
qui sont essentielles et non
substituables à ce moment votre système
économique se contracte parce que il est
dépendant de ses flux et que vous n'êtes
pas capable de les substituer par autre
chose
donc ça a commencé à petites touches
dans un certain nombre de pays dits
industrialisés la france incluse pour le
moment ce n'est pas encore un processus
mondial mais pas complètement exclu que
de mon vivant je vois ça donc peut-être
pour aborder la troisième parti
politique je voulais commencer par une
question un peu personnel vous refusez
toute étiquette politique
donc est ce que vous vous considérez
comme quelqu'un d'original dans le
paysage politique dans le paysage
écologique français et je pense que des
gens qui se refuse toute étiquette
politique vous allez en trouver plus
d'un quand même
original c'est aux autres de le lire
c'est par mois ce qui est sûr c'est que
dans le paysage écologique
médiatiquement visible donc celui des
militants on va dire visuel suspecte il
ya un génotype qui est assez c'est assez
marrant on dirait ce génotype parce que
il est bourré d'incohérences
vous avez énormément de gens dans ce
paysage là qu'ils sont ce que j'appelle
des riches qui n'y 1 c'est-à-dire des
gens persuadés que la technique va nous
sauver donc en gros il commence par
lutter contre les dérives de la
technique existante en réclamant plus de
technique il ya un côté que je trouve un
tout petit peu enfin voilà matière à
discussion s'est souvent des gens qui
ont une vision
ils ont quelques marotte mais ils n'ont
pas une vision systems s'est souvent des
gens dans ceux qui sont médiatiquement
visible qui dénonce mais qui
construisent peu or l'exercice difficile
quand on est face à un problème ce n'est
pas de dire on a un problème c'est de
comprendre comment est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à le résoudre et résoudre un
problème quand il est structurelle comme
ça c'est jamais quelque chose qui relève
d' alice au pays des merveilles vous
avez toujours devoir choisir est je sais
plus quel poète a dit choisir c'est
renoncer enfin un moment il faut faire
un choix
là le choix devant lequel on est quelque
part c est ce qu on se dit on profite de
la fête temps qu'elle dure et puis après
advienne que pourra
ou bien est ce qu'on se dit on a envie
que la civilisation humaine dure le plus
longtemps possible dans les moins
mauvaises conditions possibles et à ce
moment c'est pas du tout la même
le même genre de mesure qu'on est amené
à prendre mais comment est-ce que vous
êtes perçu dans un peu l'espère de la
croissance en tenant un discours que
vous venez de tenir kiki pour vous
pourrez faire peur bah j'en sais rien il
faut demander aux autres
[Rires]
et donc est de manière générale qu'est
ce que vous prenez comme comme société
pour anticiper en fait parce que est ce
que vous croyez une anticipation et dans
ce cas là quel système
quelle société vous vous prenez je vous
renvoyez recherches d'études
j'espère que dans les études enfin dans
les lectures quand vous fait lire à
sciences po il ya ce cher tocqueville
des droits tocqueville jeu super science
po est-ce que les gens qui sont à
sciences po dans cette salle peut me
dire si l'endroit tocqueville non un
petit peu tocqueville il a écrit des
choses merveilleuses sur la démocratie
il a notamment dit la démocratie rendra
les hommes court termiste 1840 il a eu
raison
donc nous sommes en démocratie on a
cherché à raccourcir les cycles partout
on pouvait partout on pouvait en aragon
si les cycles la mise en concurrence par
rapport à une économie régulée c'est
raccourcir les cycles la
financiarisation par rapport au simple
société comercial c raccourcir les
cycles et on a raccourci les cycles
partout on a partout on a essayé ou
partout on est arrivé et a raccourci les
cycles et aujourd'hui le monde est
gouverné par des tas de gens qui pensent
qu'en six mois on peut tout changer
donc le donc est ce que dans cette
affaire là on va s'en sortir c'est pas
sûr d'en sortir au sens de on va réussir
à stabiliser le système complètement sûr
par ailleurs la démocratie est un
système incohérent démagogique
c'est compliqué quand même de se faire
élire en disant voté pour moi vous allez
en baver compliqué donc on vote pour des
promesses qui ensuite se réalise pas ce
qu'elles peuvent pas se réaliser pour
des raisons physiques et ça évidemment
un jour c'est la faillite du système
c'est qu'un jour il ya un éclair
quelconque qui passe par là et qui se
fait élire bon alors aujourd'hui les
hitler modernes ils sont pas exactement
des hitler m'enfin c'est des petites
l'air et commence on commence à les voir
poindre
c'est des gens qui vous expliquent que
les anciens tous pourris et c'est la
faute
alors avant c'était les juifs et les
francs maçons maintenance et les
financiers
heureusement que les financiers fonds
ont fait un certain nombre des conneries
mais si vous voulez tuer tout ça résout
pas le problème que je viens d'évoquer
donc le donc le donc aujourd'hui vous
êtes dans un système qui est un système
qui est extrêmement court termiste une
des questions que je me pose
soit dit en passant c'est est-ce que
l'évolution en ligne de pente c'est à
dire si ce système se régule de lui-même
conservera la démocratie j'en suis pas
du tout persuadé pas du tout persuadé
c'est de la logique de base
si la démocratie n'est pas capable
d'accoucher d'une régulation du système
prenez-la contrat poser un la régulation
du système se passe de démocratie
vraiment de la logique de base
alors est-ce que ça se passera de la
démocratie pour des raisons écologiques
crois pas une seconde
c'est pas parce que il y aura un
dictateur prônant le rationnement qu'il
va devenir dictateur il y aura un
dictateur points et par ailleurs les
dictatures rationne mais c'est pas il va
pas arriver parce qu'il sera vert tu
crois pas une seconde
il va arriver parce que c'est un bordel
bah oui barrier parce que ce sera le
bordel et parce que les gens qui
aujourd'hui entendent régler le bordel
propose des solutions qui sont pas
compatible avec le fait que vous êtes à
moyen des croissants c'est un peu comme
si pour ceux d'entre vous qui font du
bateau vous êtes dans un bateau avec le
vent qui forci et puis vous dites ne
bougeait pas pas de problème
ma solution c'est que je vais
tripatouiller trois satellites et le
vent va baisser pleinement confiance je
vais envoyer les ondes qui vont bien
dans l'atmosphère là et le vent va
baisser
on sait ici fait pas trop confiance et
un capitaine qui va vous raconter ça et
il vaut mieux affaler les voiles allait
se [ __ ] à l'intérieur et comme le
disait tabarly s'ouvrir une boîte de
chez pourquoi on attend que ça passe
il faisait débat depuis je crois donc
vous voilà donc le aujourd'hui le
le problème du monde politique c'est là
c'est la malédiction de tocqueville
c'est à dire que on est poussé dans un
système démagogique et c'est alors la
préconisation là dedans c'est quoi il ya
une préconisation extrêmement longue à
mettre en oeuvre
donc qui est un tout petit peu ce qu'on
est en train de faire ce soir c'est de
faire en sorte que les lecteurs prenne
ses responsabilités sir comprennent de
quel problème
on est en train de parler et essaye de
s'organiser de telle sorte que sa
volonté
enfin comment dire qu'il fasse un choix
il y j'accepte l'idée que je vais pas
avoir ça ça et ça en même temps donc je
voudrais ça et pas ça on est d'accord
fromager pas des salaires et qui ensuite
ils portent cette volonté auprès au
moment des élections
donc ça ça s'appelle le mouvement
associatif ça s'appelle l'organisation
de la société civile etc
c'est ce dans quoi j'essaye de magie thé
avec les quelques initiatives qui ont
été mentionnés tout à l'heure qu'il
s'agisse de vulgarisation scientifique
kicks environnement c'est à ça que ça
sert et ou qu'il s'agisse de lobby
auprès des classes moyennes et
supérieures enfin des décideurs
économiques et des fonctionnaires
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire avec des
corps intermédiaires c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire avec deux chiffres gect
mais d'une manière générale vous avez
soit l'éducation pour que les gens semer
et l'incitation à se mettre en cohérence
l'autre option c'est de faire un putsch
m'enfin bon pour le moment je suis pas
écouter pour ça mais pour l'instant tous
ces mouvements décroissante hills
enfin où ces mouvements de prises de
conscience dont en train de parler sont
pas encore vraiment politisé est-ce que
et est-ce que vous pensez que ces
mouvements
ils prétendent pas à grande échelle en
tout cas ils prétendent pas organiser la
société en fait ils prétendent pas
organiser une transition
il prétend décrire un état d'arriver une
fois que le problème est réglé
mais sauf que ça fait l'impasse sur le
fait de régler le problème
je vais vous donner un exemple moi je
suis parfaitement pour que demain matin
tout le monde [ __ ] pour faire tourner
sa machine à laver mécanique sauf que la
transition c'est que vous arrêtez de
vendre des machines à laver électrique
donc il faut savoir ce que vous faites
avec les ouvriers des usines qui font ça
plus les ouvriers des fournisseurs qui
font ça plus le fait que la boîte va pas
rembourser ses obligations et que madame
michu la veuve de carpentras là va
perdre une partie de son épargne etc
c'est ça le problème à gérer
bon donc tant que vous n'avez pas
expliqué comment vous gérer ce problème
là c'est bien beau de dire tout le monde
va pédaler sur une machine à laver moi
je suis ravi de pédaler faire les
courses à vélo mais c'est pas le sujet
le sujet c'est que si vous prétendez
organiser la société
il faut dire comment vous passer de
l'état de départ à l'état d'arrivée
considéré comme souhaitable et il faut
pas juste le dire avec 3 calculs faits
dans une chambre il faut le dire avec ce
que les gens ont dans leurs tripes
parce que on a plein de trucs dans les
tripes et qu on est des êtres faits de
chair et de sang avant d'être juste des
cervelles donc il ya un certain nombre
donc les problèmes à régler dans cette
affaire-là c'est comment j'organise
quelque chose qui donne de l'espoir avec
moins de moyens sujet en économie je
peux vous dire que j'ai pas une personne
qui s'intéressait sur le sujet alors que
pour moi c'est absolument centrale si on
veut préserver un semblant de démocratie
donc de préservation des libertés
individuelles
vous avez un autre sujet qui et comment
est ce que vous dégonfler la bulle de
dette ce qu'on remboursera jamais alors
vous pouvez éventuellement créer de la
dette perpétuelle peut-être que si la
dette du rj pourquoi 5 millions d'années
enfin du rap à cinq millions dans les
cinq mille ans que c'est le bon système
donc en fait elle et jamais remboursés
et jamais remboursés c'est pas très
grave
mais à ce moment il faut pas que les
gens compte dessus pour en faire quelque
chose
bref enfin voilà il ya aujourd'hui tout
un champ qui et comment j'organise la
transition on essaye très modestement au
shift d'essayer de s'attaquer à ce
problème alors comme il absolument
titanesque on le fait à l anglaise
pendant ce temps on trouve une petite
marche d'escalier sur laquelle on se dit
tiens là on peut monter sur celle là
puis on essaye de vent mais cc c'est un
problème qui aujourd'hui n'est
absolument pas abordée en tant que tel
par les mouvements décroissante east qui
en plus en général ont comme premier
souci de taper sur les gens qui sont
d'accord avec eux sur 99% du problème
mais pas d'accord avec eux sur 1%
donc moi je crois que j'ai eu droit au
bonnet rouge ou un bonnet de croo
chapeaux de clown au nez rouge est
pourquoi dans la décroissance une fois
voilà donc cesser un jour un ancien chef
de cabinet d'un islam
le chef de cabinet d'un ancien vert qui
était un ancien vert pardon d'un vice
président de la région ile de france
m'avait dit en rigolant les valeurs ses
8000 adhérents 8 courant
ils sont d'accord sur rien ils sont
d'accord sur rien à part ce sur quoi ils
sont d'accord sur le fait qu'ils sont
pas d'accord notamment le nucléaire pour
le reste ils sont d'accord sur rien
c'est juste ça sauf qu'à un moment quand
vous gérez vous devez quand même finir
par vous mettre d'accord sur quelque
chose quoi donc selon vous aujourd'hui
il ya personne qui arrive vraiment à
portée
non seulement ce message décroissante
hills mais derrière les réponses savoir
et vous attendez moi bien la
décroissance pour moi ce n'est pas un
projet de société
c'est un point de passage obligé c'est
très différent quand vous dites à
quelqu'un qui de 0 à 20 ans courent de
plus en plus vite c'est vachement bien
tu cours de plus en plus vite puis à
partir de 20 ans tu dis maintenant
l'objectif c'est de cours est de moins
en moins victimes ça va pas non donc le
fait de devoir inverser l'évolution de
l'indicateur de référence
c'est un truc est juste inaudible donc
c'est fait même pas la peine d'essayer
ce que vous pouvez essayer de faire
surtout maintenant dans les pays
occidentaux où on se rend bien compte
que malgré tous les efforts qu'on fait
pour faire revenir la croissance ça
mieux pas et bien c'est de dire bon on
va commencer à imaginer des plans qui
n'en ont pas besoin
ça ça commence à devenir audible alors
pas dans les milieux politiques
encore que mais dans les milieux
économiques là vous avez des gens qui
commencent à être capable d'entendre ce
discours il sauf qu'à carbone 4 on
accueille à nouvel associé qui est un
très très grand méchant en diable c'est
l'ancien président du directoire de
klépierre dont klépierre c'est une
foncière boîte qui était coté au cac40
brièvement puis qu'il est parti ils s'en
sont sortis
c'est très bon cidre et c'est un
propriétaire de centres commerciaux donc
la gare saint lazare par exemple le
centre commercial de la gare saint
lazare est possédé par klépierre dont il
possède un certain nombre de centres
comme ça et il m'a dit avant de nous
rejoindre il ya 10 la croissance y en a
plus je sais pas où les gens trouvent de
la croissance a plu quand vous regardez
les ventes en volume de ceci de cela et
c'est n'ya plus quoi donc le don dans
les pays occidentaux vous êtes capable
de commencer à discuter de ce sujet tout
simplement parce que les gens le
constate dans les gens qui ont une vue
un peu large sur les indicateurs
économiques
et notamment les gens qui vendent des
trucs qui se touchent
d'accord les gens qui vendent de
l'argent donc les financiers par exemple
où les assureurs etc
eux ils ont un discours un peu différent
mais les gens qui vendent des trucs qui
se touchent eux ils commencent à avoir
un discours enfin il commence à être
capable d'entendre ce discours le dans
le monde politique aujourd'hui ça reste
quand même largement inaudible tout
simplement parce que les gens n'ont pas
de solution donc pas de solution je vous
rappelle que le pib c'est la base
fiscale à trois ajustements près vous
avez en france essentiellement des
impôts de flux donc des impôts qui sont
prélevés sur une fraction du pib les
charges sociales s'est pas levé sur une
fraction du pib l'impôt sur les sociétés
c'est une prélevé sur une fraction du
pib la tva c'est prélevé sur une
fraction du pib les taxes sur les
carburants c'est prélevé sur une
fraction du pib les taxes sur le tabac
c'est près de lui et c est un report
bref les seuls impôts de stock
c'est les impôts fonciers la taxe
d'habitation l'impôt sur la fortune
mais sinon les des impôts de stock
vous en avez quasiment pas vous avez
essentiellement des impôts de flux je
vous rappelle que voilà donc si le pib
baisse la base fiscale baisse donc les
pilotes de l'état qui ont à gérer le
chiffre d'affaires d'une entreprise qui
s'appelle l'état
ils voient leurs recettes baisser donc
ça les arrange pas du tout ce dont ils
ont pas du tout envie d'y croire
alors évidemment si on n'avait pas créé
un système dans lequel on peut pas
baisser la rémunération des
fonctionnaires serait pas un problème
oui il ya moins de pognon dans la caisse
je baisse la rémunération des
fonctionnaires puis point quoi je veux
dire j'ajuste le système à la hausse
comme j'ajuste à la baisse
mais le système qui a été mis en place
au moment des trente glorieuses et même
avant un moment où on était en
croissance depuis quasiment un siècle on
n'a jamais imaginé qu'il puisse en être
autrement
donc on a collé partout des
augmentations à l'ancienneté des machins
des trucs et des bidules pas de problème
donc là le décideur politique n'a aucune
envie d'envisager un monde en
décroissance parce que c'est un monde
ingérable pour lui à court terme
et comme il va être jugé sur un mandat
de trois ans encore trois ans de mandat
deux ans pour se faire élire à peu près
eh bien il a il a juste aucune envie
d'envisager le sujet aucune tué devant
aucune je vous remercie donc la partie
des changes s'est terminée donc je vais
vous inviter à poser vos questions à un
micro qui fait circuler
alors je vais commencer par répondre à
deux pieds
quid de la fusion en quid du thorium
vous oublier non enfin thorium vous
oubliez comme mesure principale dans les
quarante ans qui viennent donc ça oui
vous oubliez ça peut valoir le coup
alors ce qui peut valoir le coup c'est
si on regarde en termes d'argent il faut
savoir que si je regarde la totalité de
l'argent qui a été engagée en france
dans l'éolien et le solaire à fin 2016
engagé donc tout l'argent qui sera payé
à toutes les personnes qui ont planté
une éolienne ou planté un panneau
solaire du début à la fin du contrat de
tarifs de rachat garantis
c'est 100 milliards d'euros un quai de
0,6 et le coût historique de
construction du parc nucléaire français
avec ça moi j'aurais pas payer les 100
milliards d'euros donc j'aurais fait
zéro éoliennes 0 panneaux solaires et je
peux éventuellement prendre dix
milliards d'euros que je mets dans que
je donne à des physiciens pour faire de
la fusion mais je compte pas dessus
avant 50 ans donc ça fait pas partie des
moyens du bord sur la question
quid de la production locale alors il
faut bien voir que la production locale
à quelque chose qui a du sens pour la
chaleur ou pour les carburants
ça n'en a aucun pour l'électricité parce
que un dispositif de production
électrique est connecté à un réseau
national donc le barrage de serre ponçon
n'alimente pas les habitants de gap la
centrale de gravelines n'alimente pas
les habitants de dunkerque
l'éolienne planté au milieu de la
bourgogne région particulièrement venté
n'alimente pas les habitants de dijon
les électrons se baladent sur tout le
réseau
et c'est bien là la meilleure preuve
c'est que les allemands il voudrait bien
mettre des grandes lignes pour que les
allemands du sud bénéficie du vent au
nord c'est bien la preuve que c'est pas
une énergie
strictement local donc sur l'électricité
et la notion de local est quelque chose
qui n'existe pas dès que vous êtes
connecté à un réseau sur la chaleur par
contre c'est quelque chose
chaleur et les carburants donc c'est
quelque chose qui est totalement
différent parce que là vous pouvez
envisager une production locale vous
pouvez avoir du bois local donc le bois
des forts et de l'isère peut vraiment
alimenter les poêles à bois des
habitants de grenoble
voilà et en ce qui concerne la
méthanisation la méthanisation pour ceux
qui savent pas c'est un procédé de
putréfaction contrôler c'est du pet
contrôle et donc vous mettez des
matières qui sont dites fermentescibles
donc des trucs qui fermente dans un
container en acier donc qu'est-ce qui
fermente et bien des déjections animales
des plantes etc
des graisses et une fois que ça va
fermenter sous l'action de bactéries
primitives vous obtenez du méthane plus
tout un tas de cochonneries avec mais
vous obtenez du méthane
ce méthane c'est ce qu'on appelle du
biogaz c'est la même chose que le gaz
naturel ch4 et derrière vous pouvez le
brûler l'injecter dans le réseau de gaz
en faire des carburants de synthèse à
lille ils font ça par exemple et c'est
donc vous donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui est assez intéressant
alors pour fixer les ordres de grandeur
le potentiel en france il est de l'ordre
de 10 à 20% de la consommation actuelle
de gaz ce que son chief project on
préconise pour se débarrasser
l'essentiel du reste c'est de passer le
tout les logements chauffés au gaz à la
pompe à chaleur et les logements
chauffés au gaz s'est enfin les
bâtiments chauffés au gaz pour les plus
précis c'est 60% du gaz consommé en
france donc on n'a pas besoin de faire
100 % de gaz vers en france faire 40 %
de gaz vers en fait on peut même faire
encore moins que ça parce que 60% du gaz
on s'en débarrasse en passant à la pompe
à chaleur
la pompe à chaleur c'est jeu pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ne savent pas non plus
les suédois dans l'est de la suède tout
à l'heure comme d'hab' est intéressant
en suède
tous les logements dans le diffus sont
chauffés à la pompe à chaleur vous avez
deux types de chauffage en suède le
collectif bois pour les villes et la
pompe à chaleur pour le diffuse donc de
l'électricité puisque la pompe à chaleur
c'est un dispositif électrique
pardon c'est ce qui est pas les villes
c'est à dire le diffuser le l'habitat
dispersé
voilà donc en france on a moins de
surface par super par tête de pipe qu'en
suède la suède ses 9 millions de
personnes sur trois cent cinquante mille
kilomètres carrés donc il va en plus des
espaces que nous donc 70 % de forêts
donc ça va être pour voir du bois mais
par contre on est quand même un pays
dans lequel on pourrait avoir plus de
production de méthane d'origine agricole
que aujourd'hui et ça serait
particulièrement vrai si on mangeait
moins de boeuf puisque 80 % de la
surface agricole en france et dédié à
l'alimentation des animaux qu'envoyer un
pâturage c'est pas fait pour vous enfin
je connais peu de gens qui boivent de la
luzerne
quand vous voyez un champ de maïs c'est
pas fait pour vous non plus c'est du
maïs fourrage c'est pas du maïs qui est
fait pour aller dans les bois de géant
vers un pardon on marque quand vous
voyez un champ de blé une fois sur deux
il n'est pas fait pour vous non plus il
est fait pour nourrir des vaches des
cochons et perrette et le pot tolède
entendre donc vous avez une grande
quantité de surfaces agricoles qui est
mobilisée pour nourrir des animaux et en
particulier de cheptel bovin donc si on
a moins de but - 9 h
eh bien on est capable d'avoir plus de
surfaces qui sont dédiés à des cultures
entre guillemets énergétique dont
notamment des trucs qui pourrait servir
la méthanisation donc à des arbitrages à
faire alors dernière partie de la
question qu'est ce que je raconte au
président eh ben je lui raconte rien on
s'en fout de ce que je raconte au
président le président ce qui compte
c'est avant qu'il soit élu
une fois qu'il est élu il fait ce qu'il
a dit qu'il ferait et même si c'est des
conneries il fait ce qu'il est il ferait
pas ce qu'ils considèrent engagé pas là
tous depuis mitterrand là je considère
engagés par leur engagement leur
mitterrand n'avait fait 110 aux langues
des plus beaux des 60
et voilà alors macron je pense qu'il a
raté une marche
oui absolument absolument il est en
train de rater une marche pourquoi est
ce qu'il est en train de rater une
marche alors hollande avait déjà raté
une marche parce que hollande a été élu
contre sarkozy donc en fait ils arrivés
les mains libres
ils pouvaient très bien avoir promis
n'importe quoi on s'en foutait un peu
macron n'a rien promis du tout bah non
macron il a sorti hollande dont les gens
voulaient plus il a sorti
fillon
enfin sarkozy sarkozy juppé et fillon se
sont sortis tout seuls pour commencer
puis ensuite ses dix petits [ __ ] quand
même l'élection de mâcon voilà de
l'autre côté les socialistes sont sortis
tout seuls aussi et puis il a sorti le
dernier qui resterait il a donc bref il
a été élu contre tout un tas de gens
dont on voulait pas on voulait pas de le
pen on voulait pas enfin ou pas
suffisamment ne peine pas suffisamment
de merluchon etc donc on est arrivé donc
il est arrivé les mains libres il
pouvait faire ce qu'il voulait il
pouvait faire ce qu'il voulait ce qu'ils
voulaient non non il n'est pas au
courant parce que ce qu'on se dit ce
soir ça s'apprend pas en se faisant
élire président ça s'apprend en prenant
des cours en se documentant etc je vais
vous sortir une anecdote que je trouve
hilarante entre déprimante que vous
voulez il se trouve que depuis deux ans
je fais court à l'énap donc le programme
de l'ena sur la transition énergétique
et climatique se compose royalement de
deux heures et demie de cours magistral
de votre serviteur plus quatre heures de
petite classe derrière ces deux noms
mais a rigolé parce qu'un début l'année
dernière c'était 2
pour les traiter des questions pratiques
derrière à la fin du cours magistral de
cette année il ya un élève étrangers
soit dit en passant qui à la fin du
cours me dit ah mais monsieur mais
dites-moi est-ce que les politiques sont
au courant de ce que vous racontez là
les mignonnes donc donc le président ce
qui compte c'est qu'on ferme la
discussion qu'on a eue tout à l'heure on
s'en fout de ce que je raconte ce qui
compte c'est ce qu'il a dit avant de se
faire élire et si il n'a rien promis
sa capacité à s'emparer dans les deux
mois qui suivent du chantier en question
alors macron il avait un boulevard
il avait un boulevard parce que il avait
un boulevard banon dans les grands
dirigeants du monde occidental au moment
où ils arrivent
l'allemagne est en fin de parcours
électoral et on sait que la réélection
de merkel va être compliqué trump eu dix
mois le climat ça m'intéresse pas exit
preuve
rajoy est emmerdé avec ces catalans
l'italie on sait même pas où est le
numéro de téléphone et les anglais sont
en plaindre excite et le japon a jamais
été un acteur influent sur la scène
diplomatique internationale comme
l'allemagne reste depuis la dernière
guerre
donc il n'en reste qu'un bon alors il
commence à bomber le torse en disant que
tous les chercheurs qui aime pas trop me
viennent chez moi c'était un tout petit
début mai il avait un boulevard pour
dire moi je vais inventer pour de vrai
l'économie décarbonée
bon il est pas du tout partie dans cette
direction aujourd'hui il fait tout un
tas de trucs mais vous l'entendez pas
tenir un discours de société 10 ans et
ça je vais faire ça va être ça mon grand
projet
kennedy est allé sur la lune - l'une à
moi ça va être ça vous l'entendez pas
dire ça donc qui fait un grand discours
à l'occasion du wpt planète si vite
c'est mais pour le moment c est quand
vous regardez ce qui est en train de se
passer au niveau des ministères en ce
moment dans les dents les choses
pratiques la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie etc
on est dans la droite ligne des
conneries de hollande pas changé vous
avez épuisé votre crédit de parole
mais je lui dis rien si j'ai répondu à
votre question je lui dit rien parce que
ça se joue avant alors cette question je
vais répondre d'une phrase vous avez une
base minimale au sens du chiffre project
à ce qu'il faudrait faire sur un site
qui s'appelle dit carbonneau europe.org
donc dit carbo niles en anglais avec un
z yourope mais toutes attachées dont il
ya qu un seul lieu au milieu dit
carbonneau europe.org vous regarderez
dessus on a fait avant les dernières
élections présidentielles
un manifeste et neuf propositions
c'était un peu dans l'esprit du pacte
écologique et les neuf propositions sont
des propositions pour nous un
incontournable si on veut être sérieux
sur la question climatique
donc c'est dubost av voilà emmanuel
macron candidat a signé notre manifeste
nous a dit vaut pour neuf propositions
sont vachement bien non non il est pas
au courant il a signé non pardon juste
pour finir là-dessus michel rocard ça
rappelle quelque chose à un certain
nombre d'entre vous bat michel rocard
dans ses mémoires écrits vous savez
premier ministre alors présidence pareil
c'est un job infernal toutes les deux
minutes vous prenez une décision sur un
dossier que vous avez pas eu le temps de
parcourir
donc ça se joue avant
alors en théorie si en
la provision pour risques encore que si
vous regardez la partie ressources et
aussi le problème c'est que alors moi
j'ai longtemps été un très grand
partisan de la taxe carbone on a même
fait avec mon associé actuelle très bon
du très joli bouquin qui s'appelait le
plein s'il vous plaît qui était une
déclaration d'amour à la taxe carbone
depuis je suis un peu revenu non pas que
je pense que le système est mauvais en
lui même et je pense que les niveaux de
prix auquel il faut monter pour que le
système commence à devenir efficace son
ordre
or d'entendement aujourd'hui pour le
commun des mortels bien que en fait si
on veut que le système commence à
vraiment se réorienter il s'agit pas de
monter à 50 euros la tonne il s'agit de
monter à 5000 oui monsieur à votre tête
on voit bien que 50 vous êtes prêts à
payer 5000 un peu moins même si vous
pensez que la planète c'est important
donc mais c'est exactement ça
donc quand je dis 5000 à mon avis c'est
encore en dessous de ce qu'il faudrait
faire
donc aujourd'hui alors je vais vous
alors le marché des permis d'émission
est un système qui est malheureusement
inopérant pourquoi ils étaient nos
parents parce que la commission
européenne qui a mis en place ce système
reflète le consensus politique des pays
membres faut par contre la commission a
une vie autonome indépendamment des pays
membres en ce moment la commission est
très largement allemande
tout simplement parce que les allemands
des places des dépôts les moyens qu'il
faut pour exister politiquement auprès
de l'organe de pilotage de l'europe les
français sont nuls à chier le la
représentation française à bruxelles
elle est plus petite que la seule
représentation du land de bavière
donc pour pour revenir à 7 cette
histoire européenne donc l'europe qui
n'avait la possibilité qui n'a pas la
possibilité de faire des instruments
fiscaux capable de possible de faire des
taxes il faut l'unanimité pour ça donc
il ya toujours quelqu'un qui va vous
dire non a fait un marché de quotas et
elle a fait un marché de quotas en
postulant puisque c'est inenvisageable
dans le bol du monde politique de
postuler à autre chose que la croissance
allait continuer donc la vad son dont on
a construit le marché de quotas c'est
que ça allait croître un peu moins vite
bon alors évidemment quand le pib s'est
cassé la gueule à cause de la
raréfaction énergétique qui a démarré en
on s'est retrouvé qu'un surplus de
quotas donc aujourd'hui les quotas sont
à 5 euros à 5 euros vous avez par un
investissement industriel pour éviter du
co2 qui soit rentable sauf 3 3 3 bouts
de machin dans les coins quoi donc
il se passe rien de sérieux alors je ne
crois plus aujourd'hui compte tenu des
échelles de temps qu'on va y arriver
avec des instruments économiques parce
que pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur pour régler le problème du
climat au sens de tenir la barre des
deux degrés sous le seuil des 2 degrés
il faut que d'ici à ce que les deux qui
sont là les ménages
on est divisé les émissions planétaires
par trois voilà c'est ça les deux degrés
jamais vous allez y arriver avec un seul
instrument économique et je vais vous
citer une quelque chose une jolie
conclusion pain d'un homme qui pourtant
est un économiste qui s'appelle hilaric
landes qui est un des fondateurs de
dauphine et qui a dit on ne réglera
jamais le projet du changement
climatique avec des instruments
économiques il faut que ça devienne une
norme sociale une norme sociale c'est
quoi c'est que vous n'avez pas le droit
de tuer la personne qui est derrière
vous la même si elle me sort par les
trous t voilà c'est juste interdit c'est
pas il suffit pas de payer ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est interdit
vous le faites vous aller en taule
riches pauvres pas de différence ça
c'est une norme sociale
c'est juste interdit et bien si le
changement climatique ne se met pas à
faire l'objet d'une norme sociale qu'il
ya un certain nombre de trucs c'est
juste pas bien de les faire d'accord
comme vous mettre les doigts dans les
trous de nez quand vous êtes invité à
dîner voilà c'est juste pas bien de le
faire vous le faites pas c'est pas une
question d'argent c'est vous le faites
pas et ainsi lutter contre le changement
climatique ne devient pas une norme
sociale on s'en sortira jamais c'est une
forme de réponse à votre question
donc si on cantonne à auchan de
l'économie c'est bien de faire des trucs
sur le plan économique mais c'est
sûrement pas suffisant vous
vous en avez un chevelu tout au fond il
a levé la main très très tôt voilà donc
il ne faut pas le mal traités
0e
en prime qu'ils existent
pas et c'est un problème qui n'existe
pas parce que il n'est pas repris dans
la presse il ya deux raisons à ça la
première des deux raisons c'est que tous
les gens qui sont dans cette salle on
appris un truc qui est faux mais
largement répandue qui est que vous avez
une élasticité prix volume c'est-à-dire
que si on se met à banques et d'une
ressource
son prix augmente et plus vous en
manquez plus son prix augmente
malheureusement c'est vrai au début faut
ensuite dit autrement si demain matin
vous avez une énorme partie enfin une
grosse partie de la capacité de
production mondiale qui disparaît à très
court terme vous allez avoir un énorme
choc pétrolier ce que sera le prix du
pétrole trois ans après vous en avais
aucune idée parce que l'économie sera
effondré par manque de pétrole et le
pouvoir d'achat résiduelles des gens qu
auront encore de l'argent vous savez pas
ce qui pèse face à la capacité de
pétrole
enfin la capacité de production qui sera
toujours là à ce moment là donc vous
n'avez strictement aucune élasticité
donc ce que voient les politiques ou ce
que voit la presse c'est ça monte ça
redescend donc si ça monte et que ça
redescend c'est que le problème résolu
et ils ne comprennent pas que la
dépendance de l'économie à l'énergie est
une dépendance en volume est pas une
dépendance en prie je vous dit tout à
l'heure le prix de l'énergie est enfin
l'énergie et gratuit compte tenu des
services que ça rend donc le la
dépendance elle est en volume mais comme
n'y a pas de lien entre les prix et les
volumes
les gens s'excitent un peu quand le prix
monte puis ils arrêtent de s'exciter
quand le prix baisse
donc le problème n'existe pas chez eux
et comme ils regardent pas les
statistiques de disponibilité physique
de l'énergie en europe les regarde pas
il n'existe pas alors il y ait une
deuxième raison est ce que le problème
n'existe pas dans la presse c'est que
vous n'avez pas de guichet unique
d'accès à l'information pour ces sujets
là en ce qui concerne le climat la
communauté scientifique a réussi un tour
de force qui la création du giec
parce que le gie accès quoi c'est le
guichet unique d'accès à l'information
d'accord la communauté scientifique a
fait l'effort veut dire on va se mettre
en rang serré la en rang par deux et on
va avec un seul document vous résumer
tout ce que les disciplines
scientifiques qui sont compétentes sur
le sujet ont à dire
donc je prends des glaciologues des
vulcanologues des des biologistes des
géochimistes des dynamicien de
l'atmosphère des océanographes et ses
jeux l'école tout cela
en file indienne les oblige à se parler
et je vous sers la cuisine complète
1 entrée plat dessert qui vient de ce
que ces gens là m'ont raconté guichet
d'accès unique à l'information sur
l'énergie vous n'avez pas ça et en
particulier sur la disponibilité et des
combustibles fossiles ça n'existe pas
tout ce que vous avez sur la
disponibilité des combustibles fossiles
c'est que les sociétés privées qui
détiennent 10 % des réserves dans le
monde 90 % celles des sociétés d'état
10% et qui sont cotés par deux hommes en
plus il faut qu'elle soit côté déclarent
leurs réserves privées aux organismes de
surveillance finir de supervision
financière voilà notamment la sec aux
états unis ça vous avez mais c'est très
très parcellaire comme information donc
vous n'avez absolument pas un suivi
régulier dans la presse des indicateurs
donc si on suivait le pib / sûr si on
suivait l'énergie sur serre ils ont
comme en suit le pib sur ces régions qui
seraient au courant mais comme on le
fait pas ils sont pas au courant quand
vous parlez au directeur général de
l'énergie de la commission européenne
monsieur dominique ristori adam charmant
par ailleurs qui possède une très belle
villa en corse eu non mais il est en
plus très sympa c'est juste pas le sujet
que vous lui parlez du pic de production
du pétrole ils vous regardent comme si
vous étiez martien pour lui il n'y a pas
de sujet d'accord l'europe a beau jour
d'hui consommer 17% de pétrole en moins
qu'en 2006 17% ce pas rien uniquement
pour des problèmes de défaut
d'approvisionnement
j'insiste c'est pas du tout pour des
raisons climatiques que ça nous est
arrivé c'est pour des raisons de défaut
d'approvisionnement
le problème n'existe pas prêt n'existe
pas donc vous vous ne pouvez pas traiter
un problème qui n'existe pas c'est un
peu compliqué
donc vous avez un vrai sujet
en la matière c'est que l'information
n'est absolument pas partager et donc du
coup les gens s'occupent pas du problème
alors je ne crois pas une seconde qu'on
va faire 500 térawattheures de gaz
divers renouvelables en france il ya
juste pas le potentiel pour faire ça il
n'y a pas assez de cultures non
alimentaires à méthaniser ils sont pas
donc aujourd'hui si vous n'êtes pas en
poche alors vous êtes en gaz fossile la
balance et la balance commerciale
française se porte beaucoup mieux avec
des pompes à chaleur qu'avec des
importations de gaz fossile
on a fait les calculs à carbonne katia
juste pas photo avec les pompes à
chaleur aujourd'hui tout ce que vous
emporteriez c'est des compresseurs parce
que la france ne fabrique pas ses
propres compresseur j'ai essentiellement
de fabrication japonaise mais c'est le
compresseur ces quelques centaines
d'euros de composants dans une pompe à
chaleur qui installe et livrés etc pour
quelques milliers d'euros donc c'est pas
c'est pas discriminant alors ce qui
concerne l'électricité
effectivement vous importez l'uranium
mais c'est un euros par mégawattheure
donc c'est vraiment pas grand chose soit
dit en passant vous apporter beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui quand on fait du
solaire ou l'éolien vous importez 20 à
30 euros par mégawattheure donc quand on
passe du nucléaire au solaire ou à
l'éolien on augmente les importations à
production constante et ont détruit de
l'emploi macroscopiquement on en crée
dans la filière mais globalement on en
détruit
donc aujourd'hui je ne la limitation
physique c'est qu'on ne fera pas 500
térawattheures de gaz renouvelables et
donc on il faut bien trouver une manière
de supprimer une partie du gaz fossile
alors il ya plusieurs manières de le
supprimer vous pouvez isoler les
logements ça fait partie des
préconisations du schiste donc si vous
allez regarder les neuf propositions
qu'on a fait il ya ce qui concerne le
logement
l'optimum économique en gros c'est vous
diviser la consommation d'énergie par
deux pas vous faites pas des bouteilles
thermos soissons les gens ils
supporteront pas ils ouvrent les
fenêtres etc
parce qu'il faut aérer donc vous épices
mais avoir des preuves de moisissures
dans les trucs qui sont trop confiné
donc vous ouvrez vous / dont par deux la
consommation d'énergie et vous passez
tous les gaz et fuel à la pompe à
chaleur
et quand vous regardez ça c'est
l'optimum en termes de décarbonation
de l'emploi français enfin parce que
deux balances commerciales et de
rentabilité économique pour les ménages
tient en gros quand vous faites ça c'est
là qu'en cumul et c'est là que le ménage
qui retrouve le plus si votre objectif
de départ qui est le mien c'est de
supprimer totalement le co2 un jour ou
l'autre
alors je connais pas la société vous
mais je connais un de ses collègues en
suisse s'appelle bernard mateille pas si
vous connaissez qui est un grand pro
élite de la chose aussi
voilà donc le stockage thermique est
évidemment un truc qui a un bien
meilleur rendement que la production
d'électricité alors la situation de la
solution vous décrivez à l'éval pour la
construction neuve elle est pas valable
pour la réhabilitation de l'existant
c'est le problème mais c'est évident que
de stocker de la chaleur est quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus pertinents
ça se stoppe beaucoup plus facilement ça
se stoppe beaucoup mieux sur beaucoup
plus longue et c'est que de stocker
l'électricité oui ça c'est je suis
d'accord sur la partie alors on n'a pas
encore parlé nucléaire très rapidement
le nucléaire fait partie aussi
c'est un débat encore plus maltraités ou
aussi mal traités que celui sur le
pétrole on va dire c'est à dire que
c'est un débat dans lequel quelques
poncifs journalistique en général fo en
place les faits observables
je vais quand même en donner quelques
uns la durée de fonctionnement d'une
centrale n'est pas gravé dans le marbre
on voit n'importe quoi dans le monde
entre des gens qu'on déguise s'arrêter à
40 et des gens qui vont jusqu'à 80 dans
une centrale où quelques dizaines
d'années le seul truc qui a survécu
c'est la cus tout le reste a été changé
donc en fait la durée de vie d'une
centrale elle est conditionnée par la
durée de vie de la cuve tout le reste se
change et la cuve à les surveiller
évidemment c'est ça qui fait l'objet des
visites décennales de l'asn
en france le chauffage électrique et
l'eau chaude sanitaire électrique donc
les ballons d'eau chaude
c'est de l'ordre de 100 térawattheures
de consommation électrique sur une
consommation électrique totale qui en
fait un peu plus de 400 donc c'est un
gros morceau c'est quand même pas la
totalité
et là dedans le chauffage électrique
résidentiel stricto sensu donc sans
l'eau chaude sanitaire c'est de mémoire
40 donc c'est quand même pas énorme
en face de ça vous avez 4 100
térawattheures de chauffage fossile donc
100 térawattheures de chauffage
électrique 4 100 térawattheures de
chauffage fossiles pétrole et gaz
le mois le fait d'avoir du nucléaire en
france me gêne pas du tout en fait je
vais même dire linverse aujourd'hui ne
pas développer le nucléaire dans le
monde c'est augmenter le risque global
et bien c'est augmenter le risque global
parce que ça veut dire que on va plus
vite vers un état soit de manque de
combustible fossile soit de changement
climatique aggrave et dont les
conséquences potentielles sont cinq
ordres de grandeur au dessus de ce que
vous pouvez avoir dans le pire des
accidents nucléaires
et quand je dis 5,7 souhaitent plus tôt
cette même donc le donc on n'est pas du
tout sûr les mêmes les mêmes registres
voilà justin dans quelques anecdotes qui
peut vous amuser le plus vieux stockage
de déchets nucléaires au monde il a 2
milliards d'années il s'est fait
naturellement dans un réacteur naturel à
au clos l'installation production
énergétique qui a tué le plus de gens au
monde lors de son dix ans youn mans
c'est un complexe de barrages en chine
qui s'est rompu dans les années 70 70 et
qui a fait n'importe quoi entre 20 et
100 mille morts
on sait pas exactement parce que les
statistiques sont pas faciles à obtenir
vous avez un organisme onusien 30 ans
plus âgé que le giec qui s'appelle une
star donc une agence onusienne dont le
mandat est de compiler la littérature
scientifique disponible sur les effets
des rayonnements ionisants sur la santé
d'accord donc c'est très exactement
l'épreuve de fukushima tchernobyl et
c'est dans la presse française ne parle
absolument jamais alors qu'il a la même
crédibilité que le giec est évidemment
il ya des trucs qui sont
considérablement moins alarmiste que mes
petits copains greenpeace ou autre donc
le le débat sur le nucléaire est un
débat qui comme le débat sur le pétrole
et peut-être même encore plus que le
débat sur le pétrole est un débat qui se
base sur des malentendus des poncifs
journalistique des slogans de la
démagogie et je suis très triste je veux
le dire en public pour la première fois
que l'ami julo s'engage dans cette
démagogie qui l'a tant combattue quand
il était de l'autre côté de la barrière
vraiment ça me rend triste
aujourd'hui avec quoi vous faites le
métal des éoliennes avec du charbon avec
quoi vous faites le cuivre des éoliennes
avec du pétrole et du charbon avec quoi
vous transporter tout ça avec du pétrole
avec quoi vous faites le béton dans
laquelle vous mettez le socle de
l'éolienne avec du gaz et du charbon
avec quoi vous allez faire fonctionner
les engins de mines qui extrait toutes
les tous les petits métaux que l'on va
trouver dans une éolienne avec du
pétrole
les pneus sont faits avec du pétrole
l'engin de miner fait avec du métal donc
avec du charbon
oui donc aujourd'hui sans hydrocarbures
vous n'avez pas les dispositifs annexes
vous avez du reste pas plus le nucléaire
parce que vous avez besoin aussi
d'engins de mines pour aller chercher le
minerai d'uranium et c'est donc le
l'idée que dans une société qui va
rapidement contracté son
approvisionnement en hydrocarbures vous
allez développer tout le reste
non ça marche pas ce qui compte à cause
de la première loi de la thermodynamique
la cote du premier principe de la
thermodynamique ce n'est pas la quantité
totale d'énergie que vous avez dans
l'environnement c'est son caractère
diffus et facilement concentré ou
facilement concentre à bhl le
rayonnement à 3 kelvin du vide est
probablement la plus grande source
d'énergie que nous ayons dans l'univers
et vous n'en ferez jamais rien jamais
rien on est d'accord
j'ai donc la quantité d'énergie que vous
avez à votre disposition ne vous dit
rien tant que vous n'avez pas associés à
cette énergie soit de l'entropie soit de
l'exercie enfin une une de ces deux
caractéristiques qui vous donne le
travail utile qu'on peut en sortir
le rayonnement solaire il est abondant
mais très diffus et concentré ce
rayonnement pour en faire une énergie
qui vous permet de faire passer une
voiture de 0 à 100 en quelques secondes
demande un travail absolument
considérable absolument considérable
c'est donc je suis pas en train de dire
j'ai pas dit que la décroissance de la
souhaitait j'ai dit on n'y échappera pas
c'est très différent j'ai précisément
dit on n'y échappera pas c'est pas je
suis pas enfin dire je le souhaitais je
tiens il faut faire avec
mais si votre taille va croître et
décroître et un jour vous mourrez
voilà vous êtes pas immortel et vous
avez encore une fois vous allez battre
sur toutes les ressources non
renouvelables c'est les maths c'est
juste des maths si vous avez une
démonstration probante invalidant ce
théorème de maths publié là je pense que
vous êtes célèbre mais c'est les maths
bon bah merci beaucoup je suis désolé on
va devoir s'arrêter là mais je pense
qu'on peut applaudir une dernière fois
qu'ils ont mal voté
[Applaudissements]